[Music]
hey here we are folks that was like my
little and we just lost our last female
listen she's gone uh good to be here we
got a special guest coming in a few
minutes one of our fa so stick around
you got that right oh yeah it's freezing
in this town it's cold I got Long John's
on do you yeah I did it last night I day
Long John's feels weird to me it's not
that cold yet I know and at night you
get that wof of ball stench not good cuz
they're just cooking in there it's a
smegma it's a bio it's a sour it's
something something R you just smell
your balls after wearing them and you're
like d Ain great I enjoy it I get like a
hit I'm like it's like uh like ether one
of those things you crack you know in
fear and loathing that's the best ball
sweat ball sweat that's you get like
that real I mean we're getting too
graphic here this pretty bad I like that
I said we lost her now we lost our last
yes and there goes the gay
one sorry folks but uh yeah it is
getting it's getting chilly man oh yeah
the holidays are here I saw the dingdong
guy the with the Bell the Salvation Army
yeah the tree is up it's happening it's
officially is that time a year where I
you know I'm doing like Buffalo coming
up and Madison coming up and I bring
James Webb on the road with me and he
booked a flight where he lands like 400
p.m. in Buffalo I'm like that's rookie
yeah it's buffalo in December dude
I know you're going to what why do our
agents do this like I remember going to
Winnipeg and Edmonton in January I'm
like Winnipeg is something else below 40
when I was there once oh and I was in a
comedy condo and I remember it's like
the saddest part of the condo is seeing
what's in the fridge and you yes you're
like a detective and you're putting
together who was there you're like
you're like almond milk it was an LA
comic you know oh that's so true but uh
that was a depressing condo I remember
yes very depressing but it's it cool
winipeg is not bad no no good club
rumors yeah yeah it was good but I mean
uh and they had like a cool Rex center
it's like this it's so sad the you
look forward to when you're on the road
I know I know that's true but I would
eat everything in those
condos there we go we got him good to
have you baby St roast
everybody this is so funny get in here a
little intro for you we've been got piss
go piss go piss
roll you look like I'm back from school
all right well the short bus landed we
got Stu here it's so funny CU we're
writing this movie and we have a part
for stavos so I don't want to give too
much away but I see him I'm like the guy
from the movie I've been picturing in my
head for three weeks I don't want to
give too much away either but like
there's like three cameos I was really
pumped for working on this movie with uh
Noah Gard Schwarz and Esther Steinberg
the four of us and uh stav Dave Vel and
Tim Dylan were like the three that got
me really excited I hope we can
make this I hope someone makes it yeah
and the guy the guy and the gal writing
it are um or helping us write it are com
are Comics so they know everyone's voice
so well it's just it's hilarious yeah
it's been easy and like H it' be so fun
be so fun to just make a drinking buddy
comedy yeah you saw I don't know if you
saw the daily wires new comedy have you
seen the trailer actually looked kind of
funny it felt like an 80s comedy when he
choke slam the uh I never thought I'd
say anything the daily wire it was funny
but the the choke slam on on the girl in
the wrestling match yeah did make me
laugh a little bit I well it's just it's
funny how so much has changed because I
see that I'm like hiding under the
covers like oh my God they're going to
get in so much trouble but that I mean
this is 80s it's like soulman or porkys
or one of those movies oh yeah porkys
some of those just the anti-Semitism and
porks alone I'm like and I remember the
dumb anti-Semitism he calls the guy a
kite yeah like you're not even a smart
anti-semite that's true all right right
stavi throw my here I forgot about
the the weird anti-Semitism ribbon going
through that movie yeah we're talking
about porks you did you like porkys um I
don't remember it come on that was your
high school
nickname get in here I'm a Santa hat hey
nice oh I'm happy oh this is great
all right let me get in here were you
into those like 80 those 80 sex comedies
are almost like hello little how
we doing hey hey how you doing man good
man what the going on we got you
a glass of water and a Sant a soda water
I don't know what you like better
got coming in next you on
a tight schedule I got Albert
Brooks godamn we got no one we just
thought we throw a little intro for you
okay all right respect respect I know
I'm a comedy nerd but that Albert Brooks
Doc is pretty great I heard it's great
it's pretty fun are you a big Albert
Brooks guy um I I tried to watch
Defending Your Life while trying to also
get and it just didn't really land
you know the girl was maybe too stupid
for
[Laughter]
it it was like kind the movie was
bombing it was I felt myself the chances
of getting sucked off like lessening as
much as she hated the movie so I just
had to pause it and grab a titty so I
really that's you know I guess it kind
of moved it along you know it was a
desperation play I ended up getting not
the most difficult concept to grasp this
sounds like a pretty dumb okay
maybe not dumb it wasn't her a cup of
tea you know what I mean I that happened
to me with with played against Sam
once come on these are old comedy it's
old it's it's like early Woody all it
was like a play he did and then and the
girl was
adopted adopted and Asian yeah the bad
combo too soon
ye but uh yeah then she made me put on
what's that Hugh Grant Christmas
one oh Love Actually women love that and
then my dick got soft that's a great one
though to on yeah it is a dog
movie that every love it's the friends
of movies yeah you know what it is worse
than friends it's pretty bad because
friends it's like it's kind of like
putting on like Caillou for B like you
put on some dumb for a baby
just looking at that's what is for like
a 24 yearold girl in HR from the you
know 2000s it's just something nice it's
like me watching an act a Chuck Norris
movie or putting you know what I mean
putting on like it's just but
love exactly yes Love Actually just
stinks it's just not it's yeah but I
will what I like is that it is a movie
about cheating it's like all these
movies they're like that girls love
they're really if you P them just kind
of like some sort of pro cheating movies
good point like moonu is the ultimate
Pro cheating movie I haven't seen that
Ino long ultimate Pro cheating it's
crazy dude it's like the the D she she's
gonna marry um Danny with danello and
then she falls in love with his much
younger brother she cucks him with his
brother while he goes to attend to his
dying mother and not only that but I
believe believe his brother his
wife cured his mother cosmically and she
lived like in Italy and not only that
Sher catches her dad cheating at the
Opera she sees him doesn't blow up his
spot a good bro her mom has the CH
Frasier's dad is in it John Mahoney John
M and he plays he plays a a um uh like
an NYU Professor that just his
students Jesus he has like a he has like
a uh sher's mom in it Olympia Dukakis
shout out to you know sh got we got I
got a every Greek person I got
a don't have many I'm trying to get it's
like it's like the All-Star it's like
the Olympics where it's like we don't
have a lot of celebrities I'm trying to
Cobble together uh roster with me
Olympia Dukakis Stamos Jennifer Anderson
sort of claim I do the same thing with
Jews in the NBA top 75 I'm really
clinging to Dolph Shay that's my guy
yeah it doesn't help with all your
all everyone you put forward is
in black and
white everyone's like all they
they bounce with their hand like this
here comes Neil Steinberg with the layup
wow a 511
Center um but yes it's a and so Olympia
Dukakis has the opportunity to cheat and
doesn't actually he tries to her
John Mahoney tries to her like as a
change of pace like maybe I can a
mil instead of these it's an interesting
a dirt bag movie for sure but women were
all on board with these back in the day
like uh Bridget Jones Diary my wife was
watching that the other day it's all
sexual harassment like he's grabbing her
ass at the office and stuff andice right
pretty much yeah yeah it's just a modern
version but it's all harassment women
love it cluess also she like her
much
older that's based off yeah that's based
off of like another pride and prej oh I
didn't know that chain air right some
like that I taming the Shrew or
something oh that that's 10 Things I
Hate About You is taming the shrew
that's a pretty good movie that's not
bad young Heath ledge I haven't seen
that one I haven't seen 10 Things I Hate
About young Heath Ledger man he's
He's incredible Jane Austin
there we go nailed it that was a girl I
saw that in the theater oh wow no I love
that one lot to beat off to as a youth
as well all three I'm in the redhead
honestly I what else was she in Britney
Murphy a Girl Interrupted was that
Britney Murphy oh yeah no I'm thinking
of Elise Donovan I believe oh I
definitely beat off to Britney Murphy
but yeah at least Donovan had a run I
was very into redheads at the
night at the rockberry I beat off there
night at the rock you I saw night at the
rockberry in theater to D that was a
huge that was a banger dude Colin
Quinn I think we this is our second
night of rockberry reference in two
episodes F movie I love night of the
rockberry so much that when I met Quinn
it is the first thing I brought up I'm
sure he
confused he I don't like it might have
come off like I was trolling him and I
was like you know this is me fresh from
Baltimore hairless before still had the
tooth come out I'm just Bobby's like
little mini me at the
time and Colin Quinn was be like who is
this little
telling me about night at the
rockberry but I literally love that
movie Yes Shannon too I beat off exactly
to that outfit that's a hot outfit oh
dude it was incredible I love when girls
wear those arm things I don't know what
that is but I'm into it y that mean she
does ancient Egyptian yes um yeah that
movie had what's his name who's the
guy that Richard GCO they obsess
Richard same dad by the way Dan hidea
Dan hidea is that Tanga simple great
great underrated 80s flick the other one
he's also in he plays the dictator in um
the Schwarzenegger movie maybe the
best the best Commando rules
dude I've never seen it what it is like
when you think of an action movie you're
like oh everything is Commando archetype
you know when he's just like and
everyone dies but he never gets shot
I'll watch a your play sometime dude
please that's a aav I'm in Queens I've
been literally watching old action
movies and taking notes to prepare for a
screenplay I want to write so I'm like
I'm trying to become like a like a
professor of shitty action movies but
Commando is like that's the Bible as far
as I'm concern so who's the guy now is
it the rock like who's our Bo wood said
this like they're not really there
aren't that many left it's it's you know
what it is it's like there's guys trying
it's a little like the NBA where it's
like a Changing of the Guard where it's
like keanu's basically LeBron a
40-year-old LeBron it's like how long
can this keep going you know what I mean
I don't think he wants to keep going he
doesn't want to keep which John Wick for
was incredible but I mean you
look at keanu's resume overall he really
puts in a really great uh argument for
the best the best right now with I mean
just going I mean Matrix and John Wick
right oh yeah speed is an action movie
speed's great as well um Point Break oh
yeah you know he's just got like an
insane resume under the radar actually
you don't think of him as one no well
because of Bill and Ted and he had a
couple of weird ones in the beginning
but I would say Liam niss is somewhat in
the running he was he was before before
Wick that was a one and then dude I just
watched I just I mean uh Denzel Denzel
with the uh equalizer equalizer
equalizer three was they made
three of those dude it's so I didn't
know that either dud damn it's like
Baldwin there's another one third one
rules um yeah really good stuff but yeah
I don't I don't think there is like a
pure Hemsworth the extraction those
extraction movies really good I never
saw that really good okay oh Hardy's
good too Tom Hardy's had a couple yeah
he's an interesting one he's he's got uh
dsls which is interesting to have on an
action her yeah he's almost too Gerard
Butler nice like the Bee Movie i i in
fact I just watched Olympus is Fallen
you're the
one no that movie is incredible
you just ruined Tom Hardy for me I'm
looking at his lips holy come on
they should have made Hardy play RoboCop
you would have been horny the
whole time all lip yeah you're right
let's getop is good and by the
way the guy who plays RoboCop also has
dsls to the point where when you we like
they must have had a different guy cuz
you don't see it when he's out of the
helmet and then with the helmet
you're like God damn what the
is going on get Matt R in the new
Robocop let's do it I want to look at
those lips I I watch Robocop trying to
get too got jacked got jacked off
by a by a Maybe former exotic dancer
damn that that put Detroit on the map
back then bad guy in rooc RoboCop the
dad from That 70s Show that guy great
terrifying guy that's a who's
it's like a really good director who did
RoboCop I for he did like Basic Instinct
and yeah I know exactly who
it is he like elevates those movies did
he also did Starship Troopers ver Hoven
Roven right they're all way better than
you think they're going to be well they
he actually they it's art he's making
saying something and he's like like
Starship Troopers is such incredible
like
satire like that it's like they're just
you know you'd have to be stupid like
people are like whoa this is like this
is are these Nazi Illusions it's like
yes that's the whole point
everyone is a they're bad he UPS
the gore too and he UPS the tits he
always gets both of those in there like
RoboCop had a lot of push back like cuz
it is dark kid just expecting it like a
fun movie and I remember as a kid being
like what the is I saw it on TV as
a kid so I got all the good taking
out but yeah dude I am I am all on my
my uh action movie I can't
wait to um the special comes out or it's
out I
guess hey congrats yeah fat Rascal and
uh I I I'm doing like a little promo run
but once that's over I'm literally just
get like doing a month where I'm
watching like sh AC some good movies but
also just like I really want to get my
action movie down it's just in my
head where I just want to write like a
very a really dumb script you know what
I mean I just saw
Napoleon the reviews are horrible I
enjoyed it yeah Shane Shane tweeted it
was great I loved it I don't love I I
liked it who who is who's the director
it's Scott dud 856
886 rley rules he's great and he's
already getting he's already getting
clapback with the uh interviewers like
oh it wasn't great he's like you
and I will be that that is a good day or
whatever he's a sir good good no I want
to watch that I um I watch killers of
the flower Moon obviously and I watched
the killer which is Fincher I very good
I liked it very good people saying it's
not good or that's a bad
audience score for uh well it's also
what is it a three hour it's 243 240 I
mean I I have haven't seen it I these
movies do get a little and this is
coming from a guy who loves the
stupidest action movies they get a
little formula kind of like a like the
music biopics where it's like okay we
know what's going to happen so I
could see that maybe being part of it
but it's like and all it's like Napoleon
just had such an incredible story that
to try and do a movie about his whole
life is kind of that's not 6
hours long I just watched I just watched
a doc it's on YouTube It's like a s
stocking him but it's like four parts
but it's really cool and uh it's just
funny like you really think about the
amount of people he got killed me in
that last one of the last battles he
brings 600,000 people with him into
Russia and he comes back with 990,000
Jes he got 510,000 people killed and
that's just one battle that's one battle
and then and then he go that's bigest
up
right we all get one he had water loop
made I made a mistake yeah but he goes
back and then uh and of of course like
all these all the French people turn on
him and you know they have a new emperor
come in and but then the new emperor
sucks so much that like it's that
classic movie thing where like he comes
back and everyone like starts applauding
him no matter what people they do
forgive you yes yeah he well what's cool
back then is they put you on an island
they exiled you it wasn't like kill him
or put him in prison it just like put
him over there we should have done that
with
Epstein um but they put him on an island
twice he kept coming back and he was
like I love this country and they were
like all right get in here boring an
island has to be after you're just used
to war like you love war the emperor
totally yeah good movie I is so what I
my blind spot with history is that I
just don't understand when happened
in relation to other like
everything just feels like its own story
that's true if I had to if you had to
tell me what years Napoleon was in
charge of France I would not be able I
think like late 1800s ear no earlier
that's close I think it's like early
1800s he got exiled in 1815 it's crazy
think that America was all going on like
1777 that's why we got that's why we got
New Orleans so busy killing
trying to kill Russians just
sell off New Orleans yeah exactly he
needed money it funny you don't think
about colonization but you're like man
that's why Vietnamese sandwiches are so
good we got that bread totally the bre
the food's the best part of of
colonization yeah you know that the uh
the slaves and the women you really take
that for granted but the uh yeah the GRL
the slaves
I'm sure they would say the same thing
all for some douche on Tik Tok to be
like the bread is really
good but not to sound like a boomer
guzzling weirdo but I will say it's fun
to be in a movie theater and see horses
and swords and castles cuz it's just
like I watch Tik Tok all day it's fun to
see an Epic Production value they don't
make movies like that anymore reallyy
Scott's a legend legend you have
to be that's exactly what it is where
it's like you have to have Ridley Scott
a legend you have to have waen Phoenix
even even that I bet you they fought
them on like the scope of this because
oh yeah because I'm sure this is much
more expensive than a you know
superhero movie tank I think it's tank
it is it's definitely tank it's not
making money you got to root for these
movies to do well just so they keep
making movies I know well I mean the
good thing is I saw I think this was
like Disney's first year without like a
billion dollar movie in like a long time
I saw that yeah they're really
plummeting great like I'm I hope that
keeps happening because it's like then
it's like we have to make actual
you I mean like because if the formula
of the most we only make billion doll
movies or we make like movies that cost
half a million dollars if if that's
still the formula then it's going to be
so hard even though I think it's fine I
think we could I'd fine if that's what
happens like from a personal standpoint
it's like it we'll make independent
movies I made like a little I made a a
small movie that hopefully is going to
you know hopefully it's going to go into
like festivals and like that um
like we I think comedians would be able
to do it because the way you get around
that is good writing is like sharp yes
like funny that doesn't need big
big things like that but it's like I
like a nice mid-tier drama I I love
those movies that are like $20 million
they cost $10 million not everything has
to either cost like you know
like you saw the Indiana Jones or
whatever cost however much it cost to
make and it was like that was kind of
like the best example of like who wants
this exactly Harrison Ford doesn't want
clear like he clearly doesn't didn't
want to do any of this the's pushing 80
yeah exactly it's at a certain point and
I love Harrison for it and he's a dude
we left off like action Stars you got
Blade Runner you got Star Wars
Indiana Jones but like um yeah that's
that's a good point Air Force One's a
classic The Fugitive fugitive is
incredible that's a great great
movie he's a very interesting he's a
really interesting like uh uh guy to
talk about because it's like you
wouldn't just think about him as an
action that's true but Indiana Jones I
mean the first Wars Star Wars yeah
exactly yeah patri gam it's a I guess
he's a little in the these These are
really genre movies that are so big they
kind of crossed over but yeah Blade
Runner yeah what I love about Harrison
Ford you ever heard those stories of him
going to Comic Con and they're like Han
Solo and he's like go home what the
is wrong with you go get laid Yeah yeah
he's awesome he's just been famous for
so long that he just hates his fans
still got the earring which I don't I
don't love I love it I'm go earrings
soon you going to get the loop I think
so I've decided I just I'm I'm going
away for like 4 months and I'm going to
come back looking hilarious I'm not
telling you guys anything wa what is
now I'm tired of taking my appearance so
serious
guys it's a prison having to look like
this having to look so clean cut the
upkeep the
maintenance
but yeah I don't know I got a couple
ideas I don't want to spoil them where
you g to go GRE I got I I bought a place
in Baltimore that's just like you know
I'm going to chill there for a little
bit you know um and then who knows I
don't know I'm just going to take a
little time off you should tape
Reinventing yourself you your YouTube
channel or something good idea that's a
good idea salak hello oh yeah yeah Sal
lives with me for four
months I would probably strangle Matt if
I had to see him at yeah the man you
imagine just that camera you're having a
bad you wake up and he's like so how
what are you thinking for
breakfast I told him he I did I open for
a Jimmy Carr at Carnegie Hall salaku I
snuck him in you know he's in the bowels
of Carnegie Hall hiding like a rat in a
broom closet he's got a Hawaiian shirt
on and a giant rig on his back oh yeah
he's like all right I'm going put a
gimbal in your front pocket we'll get a
full shot of the audience then I'm going
to LV up through your under your shirt
and I was like all right all right great
and I go out there and he goes we we
shoot we do the set it goes great I come
back I'm like this is gonna be some
great footage we go to a diner we get
some pancakes we check it gimbal never
was turned
on then then I go well at least we got
the audio that battery died a month ago
we got nothing out of it so I snuck this
guy in I risked it all just to get
nothing well at least you got you know a
lot of opportunities to play Carnegie
Hall exactly this is a one take Jake and
he it oh my God that's so funny I
never I should have gone with you I was
so tired and I was going to
Australia like in like a day and I just
but uh that's true Australia is that
that Trip's BR that's a long
flight yeah you know it's not even like
I mean obviously we love salak we love
we love busting his balls but it's like
there is something about I'm just tired
of being taped of course of course it's
like we're like you're literally
complaining about that with three
cameras your face it's a lot I know but
at least we are good enough friends
where I don't really give a where
it's like this is pleasant but it's like
you know and again it's like if you're
doing it for a reason like I'm going to
go promote the special I'm excited to do
a couple of the you know big shows it's
going to be fun like that's part of the
job but it's like you know it's it like
even what we were just talking about
it's like part of me is like yeah it
would be good content to I know
but it's also said I would rather I need
you know it's just like the we even
doing it doesn't count as relaxing at a
certain exactly if a camera's on it's
not you're you're working you're working
you're working you're working you
know what I mean like the comedians
coming up had like a Mystique to them
and that's like all gone I feel like
we're now like you don't know everything
I mean I think about it now like like if
if there was like Rogan in the 70s with
Dangerfield he'd be like on there
talking about Watergate and for 3
hours that's hilarious I don't really
buy the golfer tongue kid I think
there's something fishy going on over I
mean it's just but like like we all talk
so much and it's like every angle now
like why yeah exactly why do we have to
weigh in on like you know
International
politics you know yeah it's like yeah I
I have uh let's just say I share certain
uh um uh proclivities with Rodney
Dangerfield and it's like just to be a
fat drug addled whoremonger you don't
really want that guy's take yeah
you know what I mean I'll tell you what
they should do in Ukraine all
right yeah you're right I never thought
about like Bob newart is talking about
Netanyahu we don't do that you know it's
weird be a comedian go be funny I I
heard Jud made a good new heart Rickles
too now all these comedy docks touching
touching triler Rickles is just the cool
what is the Rickles you know the classic
Rickles Sinatra joke well there's that
one and there's the two the one I love
is when he's just like you know uh
Sinatra saved my life you know you know
a bunch of guys were beating me up and
Frank came over and said uh enough
yeah I've never heard that one that's a
good one I mean that's like a CL he has
so many classic no I love his in Casino
the behind the scenes where he's just
busting dairo he's like come you can't
they paid you $10 million you
can't remember the lines Q cards
come on just say it fast let's get the
out of here and was just laughing
yeah him on dirty work they just let him
go I just I just rewatched that and that
scene is insan like like it's the the
jokes are one thing but then when he
just gets to already Langs stomach goes
hello ice cream having fun in there to
his
stomach like what weird amazing insult
and it's weirdly clean and wholesome
somehow you know he's not like you fat
piece of he's like hey Ice Cream
yeah yeah he goes with a baby gorilla
yes yes that's good stuff how how was
Australia we never heard about it it's
great it's I mean it's the trip how long
were you there I wasn't there long I did
a couple days in uh Brisbane a couple
days in uh Melbourne Vegas baby bris
Vegas I will say without question they
were the worst crap and they knew it
they knew it animal that's a road room
but then uh yeah Melbourne was
incredible I popped into a bar dude you
would love this I I I had like a night
off in melburn and I was like I'm just
going to go to a bar and get drunk by
myself it you know I had a Tander
there but I'm like n he's like if you
need anything I'm like no be with your
daughter I'll handle this I find a bar
called Nick and Nora is like old school
Noir the whole menu is uh like fem FAL
cocktails hardboiled detective cocktails
which I don't think hard boiled
detectives were drinking these likey toy
they were dude it was like a I we got to
recreate this drink on this pod in a
holiday app it's called the uh it's like
a brown butter oldfashioned it's made
with rum and like it tastes like
butterscotch but it's an oldfashioned
it's insane uh yeah Peta
kangaroo you got do did the classic
stuff uh saw our old buddy James Smith
and Sydney James Smith the man did you
ever did you ever know James I don't
think so very funny Australian guy mov
back to Sydney he was like one of the
seller guys in in that crew back in the
day Australian guy tall great head of
hair ball buster like why he
why'd he move back's sick but he I I
still remember he was just a talker
I still remember so funny a we were left
Gotham once and it was the rain and I
saw these four women waiting for a cab
and I just watched him sneak in front of
them steal their cab slam the door in
their face and I watched him laughing as
the cab pulled away he was like that he
was hilarious I mean he was just such an
in a beautiful way he pulled it
off somehow cuz he was also he had a
sweetness to him too and he was obsessed
with comedy obsessed so he opens for
like Chris Rock whenever they go out
there and all that but I was in a cab
with the once we went to a house party
and it sucked and he's like why the
would you take me here mate this is dead
and I he's like let me take you to a
proper bar I can't do the accent
but I can't do Australian but uh we get
into this cab and you know we're
hammered it's 2:00 in the morning and we
head to uh a bar and the driver smelled
like a horrific Bo and he was like why
don't you take a shower it's coming
through the glass and the guy's like
you
you he didn't phas him at all he's just
telling a guy you smell like smell
like there was a night at the
cellar when uh Chris Tucker dropped in
and and they were like he's going to
bump you and James said no and they were
like he goes I'm not gonna he's a movie
star he's not a real comic I won't do
and and gnome goes I'm not going to tell
a guy who makes 10 million a movie that
he can't go on stage here and James Goes
I'll tell him
oh he got bumped but he did he did say I
mean to his credit he do it with
class but he did it Kicking and
Screaming he made a he was respect he
was a he was like a purist and his bits
were really good great jokes very funny
you you would have really liked it no I
missed it yeah he must have cuz I got
here nine years ago I think eight years
ago his comedy seller Rex were uh Greg
Geraldo and Colin Quinn no way
wow
pretty good yeah no that's awesome yeah
I that's that's a brutal flight
though I mean you were only there for
how many days and not not a long time I
got very lucky on the way back cuz I was
uh I had one of those lay flat seats
thank God and I was like you know I'm
I'm looking it's 11:30 p.m. in New York
two muscle relaxers glass of wine the
whole time I tried but when I get on the
flight there's a lady must have been an
insanely rich woman she's with her
husband her baby who's teething the baby
will not stop screaming she's right
behind me I'm like
yeah
right you should be able to legit drug a
baby on a flight yeah just hit it with
one of
these she's picking up a
boomerang I drug him she's like he's not
breathing I'm like it's okay I'm just
going to take a nap yeah he'll be fine
he'll be fine I uh yeah so she's she's
like hey my nanny is back there she has
two nannies with her in first class in
first class which is like hilarious and
she goes do you want to cuz my baby is
so loud like I've never heard a person
be considerate like this I also helps
that she's insanely Rich do you want to
switch with my uh Nanny and I was like
yes it's behind a barricade it's still
lay flat she says the same thing to the
woman sitting next to me I slept like a
baby what a nice lady considerate lady
huge yeah I mean if you have two
nannies it's probably like you know yeah
you're doing all right two nannies too
but then uh I almost missed the connect
I had to connect in LAX and I I almost
pulled a cigar at that airport
I'll tell you I was I'll tell you no
they were dude I you have to recheck
your bag you know International and then
you have to weo through security no
pre-check I was drenched and sweat PR I
know brutal I almost missed the flight
the guy as I'm waiting for my bag the
guy's like oh you shouldn't they
shouldn't have let you do this you're
and I was like you damn but
I made it I made it by an eyelash good
for you yeah why do they do that with
the close connection like that it
happens every time I'm always running
through an airport for American Airlines
for me
but yeah you don't want to be the guys
just complaining about air travel with
no pre-check with you don't even like
flying first class we got to speed
forward to the next
topic let me let me just say this wow I
sounded out of touch there I'm
sorry I was grateful on the other one
yeah you know these lay flat seeds you
know you can get so fat even those
aren't that
comfortable some obese guy in a
Southwest middle seat hearing me say
that wants to me you're talking to the
flight attendant this fman Yan's not
that good yeah just
not I said brown butter oldfashioned
thank
you speaking of uh being filmed too much
so I saw Keith Robinson last night the
Vu and uh he's got some great news stuff
he's got a special coming on Netflix
wait to see that I don't know when Keith
I think Keith is taping December 19th
and Rachel Feinstein's taping December
18th you should go to both of them JP
McDade is taping what when is it Elders
oh nice December 17th three straight
days 18
19th three killer special if you're a
weird comedy fan that is
actually an awesome week like long
weekend for sure hell yeah we're
producing JP special so plugs on plugs
and of course fat Rascal out on Netflix
now folks there you go Netflix has been
killing it like you Barbosa um what's
her face Shang Wang you know Rachel's
getting one yeah and uh I produced Dina
Hashem special which is on Amazon right
now dark little Whispers so check that
out great jokes uh but yeah so Keith is
on stage his new shit's amazing he has
two strokes for the folks at home so
he's got incredible jokes about
incredible stroke material and there's a
guy in the front row who has had a
stroke hell and it's a worse stroke than
his like Keith can be like how you doing
whatever this guy's like you're so funny
I mean I hate to do the voice I can't do
accent it's as good as you're
Australian well they sound similar
no can you move your left side
no Australian and the next comedian had
uh the next comedian had Down syndrome
and there was a guy in the front row
with even worse Down syndrome Mark take
it away no he was black and was saying
the n word too by way
Mark all right just put a picture of
Shane
Gillis all right so uh this guy in the
front row and he's like he's dying
laughing at Keith you know you know you
you know we always talk about
representation that is representation
right in front of you so then Keith goes
what the you had a stroke and I I
had a stroke and he goes you trying to
outstroke
me and the place is going ape and
then Keith grabs the guy's cane and he
goes you got a cane you got
props you know he's doing the whole
thing and it was gold it was just
murdering murdering stroke on stroke
crime and then he gets off and I was
like Keith that was incredible you got
to get get that video and he goes
your
content there you go then I open the
door for him yeah yeah as he was walking
out I talked to him for a while last
night he goes I got one more hour in me
after this yeah like that's it I saw him
years ago before even the stroke and he
goes I'm good one more Avenger movie and
I'm
good like all right that's awesome still
young too I know I know but I respect
young but seems older than he just been
around forever yeah yeah yeah uh yeah
Keith Robinson is like a CL he's just so
funny so yeah we want to
get him on here but I don't know with
with the voice it's like having RFK Jr
you
know there's a clip of Keith losing Star
Search in like
92 dude it's incredible it's like some
skinny white guy just like jumps up and
it's like yes yes you see Keith like
this mother just so
angry you can pull it up yeah it's it's
like short it's like hilarious
Chappelle won this as well
Chappelle beat Kevin Brennan
oh I mean both had killer sets I mean
like you know it's like 19-year-old
Chappelle and he does a 93 look
how cute he looks like Martin Lawrence
oh that guy's been in
stuff oh
wow that's CRA the pump is crazy look at
that
shirt that's amazing that someone just
posted that I know hold on let me see
this again
oh man poor Keith that's awesome I feel
like everyone was on that show back in
the day also lose it or something nor
was on it too yeah but that was back
then where there's like three Outlets
you had Carson Star Search and maybe an
HBO something or other yeah one night St
or what was that other one on A&E oh yes
improv evening at The Improv at The
Improv I think didn't Carolines have
something oh yeah still on the
west
side looked weird it didn't like
Caroline but well yeah now because you
know the internet is Bittersweet we
about it but it's like there's no
Gatekeepers there's too much content we
got to be filmed all the time but you're
also like I can just put up and not
think about it are you kidding me that's
the thing it's like I there has to be
some kind of B all I'm saying is there
has to be a balance right like like it
is awesome truly I mean I've talked
about it before the only what changed my
career was just posting on Instagram
there you it was like it was literally
posting videos there was no big break
there was just slowly at one day people
started coming up to me and I like like
you know you I would get like a a like
there'd be some guy who he was pale and
couldn't make eye contact and I was like
come toown fan right that would happen
to me and I'd be like what's up dude I
was yeah hell yeah dude thanks for
listening and that would happen from
time to time but one day it just like
you know remember a mom came up to me
like a nice like like a nice black lady
on like a was in Vegas on like some kind
of like work trip and she's like hey I'm
really like your comedy and I was with
my buddy Ben and he was like what the
was that it just like a nice black
mom I was like what yeah you went from
here to here I remember that you were
posting every day for a year it weird
dude but yeah so I can't complain about
that but I'm just like well random
people find you it's kind of cool i i
people sometimes will like stop me on
the street and it's the weirdest it's
like so not the type of guy I am but I'm
still appreciative like guy stopped me
on the street didn't even stop me just
walks by me and I see him like like lock
eyes with me and he just goes yeah oh
yeah like that's not the type of guy I
am like this but you know I appreciate
it no my favorite is when it's people
you have you're like really this like I
went I was at the Pittsburgh improv and
there was just like it felt like a
couple that was F both freshly divorced
and they were back to acting like
20-year-olds where they're just like
just like this you know maybe late 40s
early 50s like white couple that's just
making out and all over each other
and it's like hell yeah dude some guy
some guy with just Alice running through
his system is just him and his
lady put on their best Kohl's
outfit and came out to see me
call people gay in the front row well
you you bring out a sexual energy people
see you and they they get turned on like
I'm serious you have like a naughty
nastiness about you confidence a Swagger
yeah I mean the opening of the special
is hilarious where you you have a woman
being like you were the best oh really I
tried to do a I tried to do a little cuz
I I love like it's those like sketches
are a classic thing in in standup where
it's like I'm of I was of two minds
where it's like these just aren't funny
most of the time but there is something
awesome about it feeling like a special
when there's a sketch so I just like did
a very I was just like it's got to be
short but it's just like you know it's
like I think it's a minute long you
played it perfectly it it was perfect it
was your Vibe it was hilarious the
special killer watch I mean watch I know
you will watch it but watch it it's
hilarious well between uh us I
was at the this New York comedy club was
in the green room and I was with like
seven female Comics randomly and they
were talking about who's hot like who
the hot Comics are and your name came up
and it you did surprisingly well they
were like something about him I mean
he's he's hideous but he's got a he's
got this like Swagger your exact
words but no we you you got a A no no
it's musk yeah yeah yeah it's all
pheromones yes it's all they smell it I
picture you with two thighs and your
glasses SK and you're just munching that
is that's the dream scenario chicken
thighs yeah I did have some yesterday
hey that's the best part of the chicken
yes absolutely thank you are you a big
are you a jerk chicken guy I'll get some
jerk
chicken I don't live in like Brooklyn
has more jerk chicken spots I don't have
that's the one ethnic group food group
we don't really have in Historia but I
do like a jerk chicken for sure love it
what's your your your Greek is number
one Peruvian chicken that's great we
have a great spot in the story that I
will not say uh because I need some
things to myself but it is
awesome um and DC and Baltimore has good
Peruvian chicken too but yeah you know
I'm all over the place I mean I was just
we were just in uh like Missouri had
some the the barbecue was great
me up St Louis in Kansas City and
two of the two of the best barbecue
where you go Spitfire in St Louis I
don't I went I I was in Kansas City uh
with Caleb hering you guys know him
funny I know the name he's funny he's a
really he's he's a young com younger
comic um but he lives he's from there
and I think he lives there he splits
time between there and la and it was
just like I I was considering like just
getting some Road like you know
you find a place on the road that's a
chain and you're like this is semi
healthy I know what it is we we became
Yardhouse
boys became Yard House boys I don't mind
Yard House Yard House it has a Sal you
know what I mean it's got like a nice
salad got like a you can get a steak
Bowl you can get a little something and
if you want to be you can be
as well it's got it all right so
we're going to eat there and I tell Cale
this and he's like if you don't if you
eat at a chain and not barbecue I'll
kill myself so was like all right we're
going where do you remember where you
went in KC Elders what was do you
remember it was like a newer Place said
only open for like a year oh that's a
risk it was new but he he he swore by
okay he's a fellow plus- siiz Champion I
I get trash Gates and Casey is pretty
great I love Gates but there's a famous
gas station one that's like that's this
like this was this place was
great but it me up so like it's
so funny dude it's like it's the time is
a flat circle thing the last time I did
this podcast or maybe one of the last
time I don't remember but I was just
talking about how man I got to get it
together I'm getting too fat and
it's like now I am even fatter than I
was and I've had the same experiences
like I was talking about how up I
was in Philly in Kansas City I literally
my I was so up off barbecue I
straight up was like a girl was like can
I come over and and I was
like I've kind of had too much
barbecue i h that level of fat where I'm
just like damn bro my dick would have
been hilariously pathetic this girl
would have been like like
massaging like Silly Putty trying to get
my dick I just like I couldn't I
couldn't put her through that know I
mean it was like it was going to take a
lot of effort to get my dick well
barbecue is got to be the worst it's
just everything you don't want sugar sug
yeah sugar fat meat everything ties you
out sodum you out your get your
blood thick yes yes you got to eat it
like at noon cuz you need eight hours to
digest and just sit there before the
show that's what happened we we had it
early but it still my entire damn
and uh yeah I'm just like and then you
think like God I can't do shows after
too much cuz I don't stop I have no
willpower to stop same same and I go
hard on the sauces cuz they put those
squeeze bottles on the table and I won't
stop it feels good feels good to go
Buck Wild casy is probably the
best barbecue in America yeah it's
awesome I mean the barbecue had
was so good I mean the Texas stuff is
awesome me up big yeah that's
heavy man I get that big
dinosaur rib beef so good but
it's like and by the way in Texas you
can by the time you can spend
$140 and you're like this seems like
just it's a little excessive but it's
not $140 worth of food they weigh it out
and they you know that's the other
thing it's like you have to get there
early for it to be good oh like you have
to get there like everyone has to get
there at like 11 you have to line up at
like 11: yeah it's like that's your day
bro you just decided you're like
Franklin's in Austin that line is insan
what I was thinking of stubs but it's
incredible it's incredible that brisket
is like butter but it's like
a hooker where you're like this
is great and then after you're like ooh
I know that was a mistake the second you
bust yeah oh that's what when you when
you're even considering it and you jack
off and you're like thank you
yes for not like I feel bad now imagine
how bad I felt thank God I went to Sweet
green you know that's like a jerk off
yeah yeah jerking off yes exactly it's
just got a nice fast casual
lunch nice it's not the healthiest thing
on sweet green you got extra dressing
you had some bread but it's not it's not
barbec it could be worse it could be a
lot worse yeah yeah yeah the barbecue is
I think that's the one thing I can't do
on the road anymore like I'll I'll do it
occasionally in those cities but like if
if I have options I love a little greek
I love a little like you know love Greek
uh you know Mediterranean is a nice
Middle Ground where it's just like meat
rice couple veggies yeah you're okay
it's not the worst it's not the best but
you got your bases covered I don't touch
the Pea everything else I mean it's good
to I Love The Pea but but it's too much
I like to keep it yeah light little
taziki is that the one taziki y it stav
makes a nice T oh really you got to come
to Queens all right got to come over to
Storia I am thinking about I've told Sam
this and his dick keeps getting hard I'm
thinking about moving into the city next
whoa I I'll believe it I see it I don't
want to be pushy but I was with I've
seen a trainer now and she's and she's
like I'm like you should see stav my
he's my friend people at this gym I
think they'll like you stop you'll get a
lot of high fives and uh and she was
like let's send him a video I was like
let's wait but I like but she said if
you want to come with me tomorrow free
session tomorrow 10: a.m. what are you
kidding he's gonna let's see how he gets
out of this
one press tomorrow at 10 a.m. or I would
have considered coming up with a
different
ex but if you move down there you should
see her she's awesome we'd love to have
you in the city CU you you've got more
people to aoria than the Mets you know
you get them out there you did to a
story of what Rogan did to Austin it's
pretty annoying we want you we want you
downtown I know I really I'm thinking
about it just cuz just to do it
just to just live near me dude be a
downtown boy I just I just want to like
kick it more I know be awesome and the
thing is like what we talk about this
all the time where it's like what's the
point of like working so hard if you
don't ever get to enjoy like I love
my apartment but it is the apartment I
moved to when I had no money right it's
but now you do have it to yourself I
have it to myself not really I have it
to the podcast it's like two of
the three bedrooms
podcast studio and office you know what
I mean it's more office than it is my
I feel more like a Japanese
businessman who has to sleep or
else you know boss will your bed is on
the
floor it's low but there's a I put a
little wood oh okay okay do you like do
you like where you eat though
that's got to be like a little I like it
it's yeah it's it's weird right you want
you want like I like that we come here
and it's like a different place where I
live and even the ru garbage guys have a
great beautiful I'm just like we should
do something like this and it's like
even if I don't do it forever it's like
couple years cuz I I'm like I I'm going
to be off the road most of next year so
I I want to actually enjoy New York I
actually want to live here and I
actually want like I'll probably do like
you know local stuff I might do like
residencies and work on material that
way but I just I got to chill
for a little bit and I figur if I'm
going to be in New York my goal is just
be here spring and fall and just enjoy
New York in the spring and the fall is
the best city the
so if I could just get a sick apartment
that is unsustainable cuz I don't like I
don't spend money on anything I really
don't so I just get like the
sickest place of all time and just enjoy
it for a year or two and then see what
happens after that um I agree if you're
paying the taxes you might as well live
in the city exactly exactly that is true
yeah I'm paying the taxes that I'm
living like a a Baltimore life quality I
do love a story but man whenever you get
whenever you go through your taxes
you're just like so this is why people
leave New York yeah I know it's really
crazy oh yeah this is the first year
I've been rich and I'm like damn sucks
dick it sucks cuz Shane showed me the
the difference and I was like oh I get
it now cuz like I don't want to move to
Texas but like I know you better not
move I'm not moving to Texas I'm
trying to get this guy to the
Village you move to Texas I'll kill
myself no no no I'm not going anywhere
but it was like jarring oh my God that's
a big number I mean look I love visiting
Texas living in Texas no no same I love
visiting it's a great place hot as too
hot in the summer it would be great if
you could just live there dude I really
did the math where I was like damn maybe
I should move but then it's like if
you're on the road in the winter which
is when the the best the best tour like
that's when ticket sales are the best
people come come winter the most true
and then you have your Summers off
that's when the road is the worst right
but you want to spend it you want to
leave when Texas is the best and then
have to stay there it's 125
degrees like it is unbe anyway anyway
whatever who gives a no with I love
I love I do just love New York and I
just sometimes you just feel like yeah
this is where you don't it's the choice
has been made for all of us I feel like
could you imagine any of us not living
here it would be weird it would be weird
and every time I leave he's
barely he can't drive he needs
Volkswagen Jetta in the suburbs tell him
you know that Japanese show where they
have the toddlers going to run errands
do that with Sam and Kansas a
that's great Sam with no
help do a return at a Target in the
suburbs I haven't had a
coffee me me waiting for an Uber in
Omaha I'm like oh come on oh 20 minutes
yeah no dude it's brutal it's I'm I'm
I'm I can't function here so if you guys
left I'd be sad right yeah no I
get it I get that New York is one of the
most unlivable places ever but it is the
best the I love it yeah it you in
weird ways like you know when you go on
the road you have a great time you're
like that was an awesome trip great Club
great crowd and you get back and you
land at JFK or whatever and it's just
just jizz hitting you in the face you
know you're like I can't get an Uber the
lines are CRA I just got bumped somebody
called me an I'm I'm stucking
gridlock traffic on the BQE like
this city but but if that's the thing
it's like again we love it and it's like
what's the point of working and like we
all got so lucky to get rich what's the
point of doing that and not living
somewhere else because New York is a lot
easier Rich dude it's a lot EAS remember
how what it used to how horrible
it used to be now totally almost every
annoying thing if you spend $150 can be
fixed right like and it's like but back
when you didn't have that that was Bull
I remember the train I mean I've
Liv in the same apartment I've taken the
train like 10 times this year really I'm
in Historia so it's like I'll just drive
places back in the day it's like oh yeah
sorry the train from The Cellar to
atoria crazy at 1:00 a.m. it
would be like all right well we're
actually going to the end of for we're
going to Forest Hills then you have to
turn around yeah yeah like great oh I
remember going on the train with my
laundry and then going to a laundromat
and then waiting and the whole thing
took like N9 hours that doesn't even
make sense to me why there's not a
laundromat walking distance not where I
lived wow no I also got bed bugs in
Bushwick and my friend's like what are
you going to do and I was like I'll
probably just live with them you know I
just had to I wrote it out I just have
bed bugs I couldn't afford an
exterminator I couldn't afford to move
so I just had bed bugs I remember
Brooklyn for like for like a year I
didn't have the L train and that was my
only train home and I was like this is
insane was even you living in
Brooklyn hilar that's how much of a New
York Jew you are that do you being in
Brooklyn I'm like Jesus
Christ okay that's true that was a
different time you had those two lady
roommates I remember I slept I crashed
on that couch a few times and we watched
a whole season of Eastbound down when
you were hung over oh yeah that's
awesome I could barely move you brought
me a smoothie which I still
appreciate I I have a lot of sympathy
for anyone with a hangover oh yeah that
was after the Christmas party
oh I remember uh it's so funny that he I
like don't react to it anymore I'm just
like no joke folks sorry couldn't have
lean the other way I'm the guest here
you usually usually you do put it on me
it felt like a righty I don't know
why woo that is really why are you so
gassy what is it yesterday for food me
and a friend went to Frankie little
Frankie at pasta joint east side or Ace
Village killer I think I'm just getting
all the carbs out very nice underrated
Italian joint that is a bad fart
Mark doy good oh we got for Breeze nice
well played you went you went on Amazon
and ordered for Breeze because of this
guy's oh yeah that's for
me there you go we both got a problem
you need a more absorbent couch for
there really boun this is a bounce dude
you need you need to cut out a cloth
section for Mark's ass that's not bad it
just absorbs it like remember when you
were smoking weed in college and you
would put like dryer sheets in a
brown paper towel holder you need to
start spoofing your own
farts you can put a little mic in there
so it picks it up and then a
breeze comes out dude that's pretty good
we might invent an
instrument that's like a it is a pasta
fart I smell it yeah a real you smell
the or
oregano I had muscles too that ain't
pretty musles that's where the fishiness
comes in I love muscles little
Umami little Umami in that um nice past
maybe I'll have a little po you
know I might get some tacos after this
baby in a stor or you got there's a
place here that's good yeah mhm that my
friend keeps telling me about that I
haven't gone to it popped up on my
Google Maps I was coming here it knows
yeah yeah yeah yeah it does do you guys
ever do ways I used to be a ways guy
when I drove all the because I I mean in
B for the first five years of the comedy
I was in Baltimore but I went to DC
pretty much every night really yeah yeah
because the the scene was better and I
was when ways first came out I was a I
was a ways believer yeah and I think
Google ended up buying ways oh okay so
ended up being the same but
sometimes ways will have you doing some
have you cutting through an
alley or trying to it'll give you the
absolute best case scenario where it's
like well if you can make this left on a
eight Lane Highway you'll save
three minutes it's like awesome and then
you get there and it's like oh I'm
I'm here 15 minutes you know is
that the one that tells you if cops are
nearby I likey Co that I like and then
people help you they'll be like watch
out there's a speed trap up here you
know wow that's pretty nice that I
enjoyed and I did it for that purpose
where I was like I felt like I was one
of the good guys which like warning you
about the traps and like the cops and
but it was also very unsafe cuz
you're like typing in while you're
driving you're like cop on the right
side good point it was very unsafe yeah
and someone's like guy wrecked who was
trying to help you know on the right it
probably if you're drinking and driving
that's probably what you use right oh
yeah good point um yeah I don't know you
ever have the guy in like an Uber you're
kind of cutting close on a flight and
he's like this GPS I know a better
way that makes me so nervous I'm like
they might know a better away but they
might not I I don't know now we get
could just get stuck on a side street I
know what you mean but that feels almost
like that's almost like romantic to me
at this point because every cabbie I've
had for the last like 10 have asked me
to put my address into ways yes and I'm
just like what is going on I hate that
this feels wrong guys don't supposed to
know the best way it's like a hooker
going how do I blow you come on you got
this is your gig I know I could have
done Uber back in the day cabbies used
to have to know the map like have to
study it and then take a test on it
that's over yeah that's over yeah I do
kind of like I mean some cities you go
to you're just like this hotel and the
like on it right yeah that's you there's
four places to go right you know
but yeah I'm with you there's something
I'm I land at like Newark or whatever I
put my thing in I'm like I do kind of
miss them just knowing them I know and
then you have to just touch some
guy's
Android Jamaican
Android like jerk chicken jerk chicken
off it like Jamaican
Android all right speaking of of food I
got a peeve that is so specific that I
can only do it with a like a foodie here
yeah thanks food is what he was thinking
folks that's the word the F he was about
to
say um all right so by the way when I
whenever I see you gather like that and
you don't fart I'm shocked
he just did one of these I'm like wow
that was the p f had some heat under me
I had to let it loose so this is a silly
one this is a stingy move of me
but okay also stingy I don't think is
what you were thinking but go
ahead so you ever go to I love F yes
love a good F great hungover meal by the
way cuz it just everything have it
it I haven't had it in a while yeah it's
great and it just cleans you out you're
snotty you're sweaty it's great but hey
hey we might be drunk brought to you by
manscaped this Christmas take care of
those nuts manscaped is made cereal your
grooming is in check with a fresh ah
with a fresh launch just in time
for the holidays their new performance
package 5.0 includes the lawnmower 5.0
Ultra body trimmer the weed whacker 2.0
ear and nose hair trimmer crop Soo After
Shave lotion and crop preserver ball
deodorant I could use a hint of that
right now I got some smelly eggs I love
manscape I use that 2.0 all day
long I use the the lawn mower 5.0 it's
got a light on it it's got all the
gauges all the sizes I keep it in the
suitcase and I keep one in the medicine
cabinet when I'm on the road I need a
trim or when I'm at the home and I need
a nice buzz on that ball bag cuz that
thing gets a couple of weird
scragg lawnmower 5.0 Ultra does all the
heavy lifting with two gen blade heads
one's for taking off a little off the
top and the other's a smooth foil blade
for a close shave it's even waterproof
so you can knock it out while having
your shower routine going this set comes
with two free gifts sayy hey the
holidays are here a pair of comfy boxers
and a travel bag so it'll be prepared
for anything get 20% off and free
shipping with the code drunk at
manscaped.com that's 20% off with free
shipping at manscaped.com and use
code drunk Dr rnk uh happy holays you
qus you ever have this one you go order
a bowl of f they bring out that I love
that little plate of the goodies the
herbs you get the basil you get the bean
sprouts you get the lime and the
jalapeno okay we're all on the same page
they bring a little plate it's the same
every time I go with the wife we get two
bowls of
f one plate to share crazy come on I
know what you're doing there Vietnamese
man you but you you you must have asked
for another place I couldn't do it what
Mark I feel bad I don't want to be a
Karen or whatever you know notop being a
Karen I don't want him to pull out a
phone and go this the right
side of History here I thought so but
why why can't you just ask that it's a
pretty basic he's going to go inflation
being a
I didn't want to push it all the
opposite stav and I have had Korean food
many a times and I do those little fixs
they bring out I always ask for I love
those and I always ask for they here's a
here's a I always ask for specific
sauces of Korean barbecue because they
see white people come in and there's the
bean sprout or the bean bean sauce bean
curd sauce and the uh the oil the sesame
oil it's much more expensive oh sesame
oil is expensive right it's really
expensive they don't automatically put
it out there exactly I ask immediately I
don't even let the I don't let
the menus of the table before I'm like
we're going to need a little maybe I'll
do that sesame oil and and the other
thing is at least in the Korean place
when I do that I feel like I've earned
respect I've earned Korean respect
because I am a I'm a you know a round ey
who knows about sauces oh right right
you're
knowledgeable yeah and it's not racist
to say that it is racist it is racist
for me to picture him calling you that
it's racist do the math and why did I
say that but saying it's not racist it's
the rare you walk into like here comes
Kim
Jong now that was
racist I'm just saying when I go to the
these V I don't think Charlie likes
giving up the uh they don't like giving
up the condiments how does this keep
getting worse I don't even
know but no I do I really do think
Charlie doesn't like giving up the basil
that's all I'm saying they try to divide
it because they think I'm a round eye
who doesn't know I'm in your
Camp he he just throw camp at the end
too I do I will ask for the sauce I will
want I want to be you know marked as a
as a even though I'm white because I do
they definitely an ethnic neighborhood
and ethnic restaurants you will get sub
particularly I feel like Asian
restaurants you will get it's a fight to
get surface you know you're right like
my mom when I when I took her to we took
her to a Chinese place great place uh in
Chinatown my mom loves Chinese food
right food was incredible my Mom hated
it because my mom's a wa was a waitress
for years M and she was the waitress was
rude as you know what I mean they
just like toss the she like okay
she like what do you want what do you
literally they're like what do you want
as soon as you get there there's no
bedside man you tell them and then it's
like you know comes out at weird
times and my mom was just like couldn't
couldn't appreciate that but I'm like no
it's a fight to get the good food Ma you
can't this is what it's like for actual
I feel like Jamaican plays are the same
way yeah there was a place in Baltimore
where it was just like they acted mad if
you came in
if you think they're gonna have
everything you're you're out mind but I
do like a little bit of humiliation I do
too I feel like I a little cuz here's
the thing that's how you know the food
is good that's the first they're fresh
off the boat the food is where it's all
going to it's like the St masochism of
of a meal with they're like you little
torp see that's not that's me I
don't have that that's him he likes he
likes that I don't want to get my nuts
crushed I don't want to get my nuts
crushed by those by little house
slippers but I um but I like it because
it it portends very good food right
there's nothing that's the best you want
you want an ethnic restaurant that has
no marketing yes has shitty plates and
silver they're not on Instagram they're
not on Tik Tok none of that
that's when it's good there there are
plenty of and that's what I that's how I
feel about Greek restaurants too where
it's like something happens when the
second generation takes over and it's
over you know mean then they start
you know putting Edison bulbs up
then they start they start you
know serving on a wooden plank
instead of like just shitty
semi- plastic plates whatever exactly
and it's like once that happens it's so
and they start having good customer
service they have good reviews the best
ethnic feed you will get has three and a
half stars because there are people
there are like hoyy toyy
that come in don't like the how
rude they are don't like that the
bathroom is f that's a great point you
know what I mean it's like I don't give
a about any of that I want the
finest dish served to me I want
the tastiest of all time and that's
what you get partic I found particularly
in in most ethnic places I agree 100
it's almost like seeing a comic and
you're at a theater and this guy's
wearing a hoodie and some some hy2
person like this guy can't even get
dressed up for his own show and you're
like no this guy's going to be better
than the guy this is Dave tell he looks
like a janitor handing out
business
cards hack that's a
hacky you want the quality in the food
not in everything else hates his
audience yes you know what I mean
exactly you know uh Chinese some about
Chinese in the that place across
the street here used to be the best down
yeah it was like you get like shrimp
with with a scrambled eggs that type of
Chinese place those pork
dumplings something I think like cold
weather food for me it doesn't get
better than Chinese or like I love that
Ukrainian Russian style food love that
food were like culturally you're just
like used to freezing to death and then
they have like these amazing soups it
makes sense it makes sense why that's
the good neiz might be what you
want then they kind of split the
difference what's that it's just kind of
like thicker Chinese from lack of a
better kind Chinese and Indian a little
bit like those Momo dumplings are
incredible I like that um that's
good stuff cuz again Mount
Everest you know what I mean like it's
cold you know yeah we're just
taking the good part of their culture
yeah yeah absolutely no I mean that's I
love like a good borch in the winter man
a good it's cold yeah no
I want it warm oh no no no in the you
get a hot oh I've never gotten a hot the
seller has it interesting guy oh big
chunks of beef and carrots it's great
two
peasant interesting for the win it
reminds me of Greek peasant Food
Northern Grace like every you know
everybody thinks about like the islands
and Southern Greece my grandma's from
like such so northern Greece that's like
bordering you know the Balkans and
like that and that's kind of cold and
and that is just like yeah to me
it's like it's a bunch of soup
bunch of bean soups bunch of tomato
bean soup really what's like very oh you
don't like lentil soup nah I'm sick of
it every every Diner I go to and they go
I go what's the soup of the day I love a
Mata I love a chicken noodle rice Minon
they go we got a Yankee Bean or lentil
I'm like should I just flip my wrist now
these are your options Yankee Bean or
lentil I can't get hyped for a
chicken noodle cuz I just associate it
with being sick I love a chicken noodle
when I'm sick but like that's what I get
when I'm sick interesting yes I agree
with that I'm not a big I honestly I
need the place to be a soup place for me
to eat soup there I don't want cuz soup
is if it's an afterthought it's
just water and a couple
veggies true I need this to be your
specialty got it like that's why F even
though f is the definition of peasant
food it's like just simmering bones for
a long ass time but you go to a
f place they care about their
broth their broth is like they slave
over that I love I love ramen same
thing same that that egg the way
they do those seasoned eggs baby I want
extra eggs baby yeah there's I want to
have five different meals after leaving
here I know my Ramen and Tacos so my
lady loves to cook she just bought a
slow cooker better than the old name
cooker but
put that my ACT but um that's the old
term but uh I mean this thing's great
you come home and the thing's steaming
you can smell like oh she's got a a
Minon going oh there's a beef chili
going and it's so exciting chil that's
the good chil's good the only problem is
you got you know in this fastpac world
I'm like how long till the chili she's
like you need another three hours I'm
like God damn I get the whole black eye
thing that's a mat rif
joke can you believe how much trouble he
got in for that
um did you see I oh yeah well um it's
not look the joke is whatever it's not a
strong joke but it's also just people
are looking right right yes thing when
when you rise like this especially and
you look like
that and it's also like you know I I
haven't seen many of his crowd work
stuff but it's like you know he cares
about comedy I get it he probably works
hard on his act but it's not the
strongest you know punch lines you're
going to find the so it's like
people are just trying to take it you
know they're looking for something and
it's like whenever you do a joke that is
that that subject matter this is my
thing about Freedom whenever this comes
up with freedom of speech in general
with comedy it's like it's not that
you're not allowed to say something it's
that you have to make it good if you're
going to do something hard if you're
taking one of these like open micers
that want want to say the n-word it's
like you're not almost no one should no
I like I'm not gonna say never because
it's just like I'm you know
philosophically opposed saying you can
never say something but almost no one
should almost no white person should say
you know unless it's a really
unless you're really racist you
should unless you're trying unless
you've been canceled you're trying to
Rebrand on Fox's
streaming Fox Nation yeah yeah yeah um
but yeah so it's like that's my I think
that's what people were upset about is
just like look man it was just not a
good it's it's some people would have
been mad if it was the best joke of all
time sure but then half of people
wouldn't have and so the fact that it's
he gets people that both want to come at
him for comedy reasons and for like you
know tattletail you shouldn't say that
reasons and together that's a very
powerful force like comedy nerds and
like
tattletales together a lot a lot of
ladies who didn't love comedy maybe who
just like his face I think that's the
thing it's like he brought in a lot of
people who maybe weren't comedy fans
right right and now they're just like we
didn't sign up for that and we were like
well we do that stuff all the time I
know I don't talk about the jokes we
beat women all the
time no but uh you think you just have
to you just have to like when you get
that big you just are going to get
people popping in yeah also an opening
joke true
structurally like we you it's like start
with something soft well that's start
with something like you know what I mean
yeah I agree but that's why people think
he did it on purpose that's like a big
Theory what that he did on purpose to
just kind of shed those ladies and show
like I'm a I'm an edgy guy and now now
that I'll get dragged online I'll get
some Buzz interesting I don't know if
he's that calculated he did the thing of
like uh I'm just I'm just seeing if you
guys are you know it's it's like I would
leave that off a special probably seen
that done a time sure but that's true I
guess that's that's one construction is
like go hard up top but it's like that's
hard to follow just from a structural
standpoint like that's why I always like
look dick J there you go all right a
small sque small um I always getting
weaker I end with like sex stuff because
it's like nothing can follow a good no
no no my closer right now is my closer
cuz I can't follow it yeah that's why
it's my closer and I don't mean it's
like a great it's just like it's it's
that subject matter that would be hard
to follow yeah totally I tried a little
something different for me my entire
career has been like uh fat jokes are
kind of the great they're clean they're
a nice equalizer self depra
self-deprecating you kind of get people
on board I wanted to do something a
little different structurally this time
where I started with a little bit more
like I'm not a big topical guy you know
what I mean but I started with a little
more like you know just kind of
on the S you know on Austin
which then got into Tech stuff and kind
of on a couple things and then
I had a and then I did a long story in
the front of the special which I always
used to think like structurally should
go at the end and then I got the fat
jokes in the middle and I close on Dick
jokes so it's like I get like I did that
just to kind of around just to like
try something different like you know
try try and make yourself try and and
like you know earn more skills and make
that story funnier and snappier and make
it so you don't lose people's attention
I got to tell you the there's a there's
like a two-month period on the road
where people were checking out really
but it's like but it was too long yeah
like that's why you got to go through
that and I hadn't earned I hadn't earned
enough buying yet and it was so I get I
get playing around and maybe he was
trying to do that structurally of like
maybe I want to just do this but I think
it's all of that is the reason it was
but yeah I don't think you know I don't
think it deserve that much I mean
whatever you know he'll be fine yeah
he's going to be fine he's going to re
he's it's also people you don't get that
white hot without cooling off a little
bit for a minute but like yeah he's I
think he'll be fine I but if he had just
had if he just had not done that special
I don't think any like I don't think
yeah I don't know that J not that
special he just not done that joke I
think I don't maybe there probably would
be less Buzz about the special that was
that's the theory but I Chappelle theory
about the stuff like that's the thing
about I will give him Credit in that it
feels similar to those where it's like
everybody's talking about it is
everybody saying it's the best special
they've ever seen in their Liv know but
from a pure number standpoint everyone
is talking can't argue with the I but I
did watch a few of the because I'm like
well I want to see how angry these
ladies are and what's fascinating to me
is they'll be like well I like the guy
now I I hate him because he condones
violence against women you're like whoa
condones it's a joke about violence
towards women where'd you get the
condoning thing but it goes exactly but
it goes to stav's Theory like the jokes
when you go there they have to be home
runs right right right and that's why
you know uh I mean that's why people get
in trouble normally from podcasts when
like
Loosely structured but when when you
bring that in a special you want you and
you go there you want it to be yeah a an
a joke so you're round ey that
whole thing that's GNA come back to hot
yeah no but you know he's also a young
guy and I think when you get this this
you know heat I mean stand there's a
reason most stand-ups pop later right
true true it just I think it takes time
yeah well it's so weird it's talking
about like we're talking about no
Gatekeepers it blows my mind when I like
a six-year comic and they have 4 hours
on YouTube I'm like what you what are we
doing here like first of all how do you
have that much time secondly could it
all be great is it all special worthy I
doubt it take your time like just
because YouTube is there doesn't mean
you have to use it anonymity is wildly
underrated I thought about this a lot
right because like I was like damn these
like young Comics should not post this
much and I know that's coming from like
all of us Post constantly and it's
helped all of our careers we've been
around we've been around yeah for sure
but
uh but that's but I also think I think
back to when I was yes 324 I did think
same I did think I should be on Comedy
Central I did think I was ready for a
half hour so it's like I cringe think
like in a world where this was available
to me I would be the same way I'd be
putting out things that were like dog
with two good jokes that are the
two J like there's there's that I
was doing when I was 23 that it's like
honestly there's a joke on my on this
special that I had forgotten about that
I that I was like oh that was the only
good joke I wrote probably four years
hey it is good enough it turns out it
that was the one funny thing but if
YouTube existed in this way when I was
24 that would be like in the middle of
38 minutes of dog exactly exactly I
completely agree with you guys I think
about when we were like young it was
kind of a privilege to fail in the
shadows absolutely we didn't real like
an Mark's right being anonymous is great
I remember Mike D Stefano uh rip this
guy once telling me like he did like yep
I do seven shows a night at ha and no
one sees me and I get to work on
and I was like hm that's that's and
and it it was always I remember he would
pull me and Joe Macky aside at the comic
strip and be like it's good you guys are
here every night and and you're trying
and you're and like just get good
before people see yout and that's why I
think people often wait to moved to a
city like New York now it's different
with social media but back then that's
how it was that's how it was for me I
mean I moved probably six years in I was
25 when I came 26 something like that
you had great when you came I
remember meeting you I think I met you
at a benefit of Gotham Gotham yeah yeah
yeah yeah and I was like this guy's
got really good it's always
shocking when you see someone new and
their stuff is so home but I remember
the like the early stav joke of the uh
like ladies I won't you well but
the breakfast the breakfast the next
morning when I featured for Bobby I
like five you know five six just
pieces of trash with that joke
yeah like cited it like the reason they
and it was like you know you know
Boston mom girls fresh out of pill rehab
like IHOP should throw you a bone like
thank you for that breakfast joke no but
I think I heard bur once refer to it
like as uh
like if Robert dairo would post his like
early acting auditions and there is like
a it's a good comp but it's tough I mean
like you know what are you going to do
you want to you want to make a career
out of this I I don't begrudge him yeah
yeah for sure and I think I also think
there is something to there's so much
out there it doesn't really matter
kind of is anonymity right and it's like
the only issue is if you s like what
would be bad for a lot of people is
getting a attention too early agreed
where it's like in a weird way I think
you know I think for me as well where it
was like I didn't like I I didn't really
have any industry attention like until
now like literally until right now and
that helped me I mean yes what I'm
saying right now it's like it was this
one and that really did help me because
it was like it was a thing that I
despised you know I feel like I got
passed over for like a half you know a
half hour here or there or like a a late
night set or like you know I would I
would submit and I wouldn't hear back
and it it pissed me off but it was like
well the first time people saw me I was
so much better at stand like I look back
at my first hour the one on YouTube and
it's like it's good but even that I'm
like damn oh worst comic now or I'm a
I'm a I was a worst comic fan and that
wasn't that long that was I filmed that
two years ago damn you know what I mean
and I just feel like I just feel like
this special is so much better that it's
like and that and I was good don't get
me wrong it's a good special I'm proud
of it but it's like what was I like even
2 years before that exactly it's like or
two years before that and so I was
really lucky that I just kind of you
know nobody really gave a I got to
make connections with good Comics people
you know you guys all like helped me out
and like I got to do shows with good
Comics but it was kind of under the
radar and then it was like when when I
just started posting it was like I I
kind of had a glut of I had taped
cuz I was Al such a comedy like sick
aant that I would take my shows and like
watch sure and so I just had a whole
Year's worth of that I was like
well I've got it I might as well
post it and so by the time people
started paying attention I was already
good at comedy but it's like if that had
happened when I suck and that but you're
saying you sucked I we knew you and I
have no memory of you sucking yeah but
you know what I mean I could have done
an hour like if
people people go viral and then they
have to people come out to see them on
their first run and it's dog you
might they might not come back I got
really lucky where it was like I felt
overdue so when people came to see me
they were like surprised I was good that
would happen with come toown too where
people were like they just want to see
the guy from the podcast and then it was
like oh I'm actually good at comedy and
that helped me kind of grow my road
business and the internet helped me just
kind of take it to the next level you
know you went you went the reverse way
of most Comics as you're saying because
like you had fans before you were even
like clubs were letting you headline
right right right which is like pretty
weird dude I had some hilarious emails
from places that were like we can give
you $50 to do a Sunday show and I was
like
no I just I dude I would send them like
emails with my podcast metrics and I
like w here's what I think I you know
compare similar size cities I sold this
amount of tickets like I did I
would put little presentations and some
people were like oh sick it would let me
do it and some people were like well
that's all well and good but you can
have the 400 p.m. for $100 no flight no
Hotel I was like okay no
yeah dude somebody offered me to do
their contest there was there
was a CL that I I you know that I'm
still I still hold the grudge over that
was like they wouldn't even let me
feature I don't think W you know we can
believe it it was the it was
really I have a weird story cuz that guy
actually helped me out so much when I
was too him that
but sometimes you can screw them cuz you
go oh you don't believe me just give me
the door I'll do it for the door you
keep it and like you got it I the
door all the no I always wanted the door
because that's I always felt like you
know but yeah so fair yeah you bet on
yourself totally and it's like and it
only it only didn't work one time every
time I would I would made I made money
you know anyway but yeah it was a weird
situation where it was like people were
coming out and there was a little like
corralling people who just wanted
podcast stuff and I was but it was cool
for me because I I got to like get a lot
of fans cuz the only reason I did a
podcast was for stand up yeah of course
so it was like it it helped cuz some of
those people don't know that you know
but I remember when it was happening and
you would open for Tom Papa and Tom Papa
would say like stav's got fans like he
would like crack up cuz you guys are
such different acts like but like your
you're people are coming to Tom Papa
show he's in a suit like that was funny
Tom is uh he's the best he's the best
he's the King yeah uh we we just
were randomly doing the exact
same this is how good ComEd is right now
was like me and Papa were both in
theaters in the same cities sold out and
it was and we both stopped we
got to meet and get breakfast together
when just like driving from St Louis to
Kansas City we stopped in
columia Missouri wow and had
breakfast together it was awesome I did
a weekend there once Deja Vu comedy club
quit bragging strip club well it kind of
was it was it was like it was like a
comedy club than a nightclub I think
that was my open room like does each Rog
does each floor down get sadder you
comedy is oh sorry oh no no go ahead
comedy is crazy hot right now I just did
Denver Brad Williams is at the club he
sold it out like adding shows Hassam
Minaj is at like the mini Arena I did
the Paramount and then Josh Blue did
some little we all got
breakfast and it was like I I said we
got we got a Muslim a and a slow
cooker yeah walk into a
bar all right Mark only met them so we
could tell that joke
that's a that's a cool group though
great group and a weird mishmash fun
group yeah I mean and it feels stupid
for me to be like I have to take six
months off in the middle of this because
it does feel like the hottest I just
feel like comedy's go but it's like it
ain't going away I hope you're right I
mean we are in a for you I I I think
you're going to be in great and also
like specials are just out so yeah yeah
hopefully yeah dude it's it's I think
it's your best stuff I mean it's the
last stuff was really funny I love all
your stuff but uh you know there's a
short list of comments who specials I
watch you know and you guys and then
just a few other people appreciate it
yeah you're so I you're such a comedy
fan and you like are good friend where I
sent you a little clip cuz I was worried
about the sound and he wanted to just
watch the special he's the man's the
best we uh we had corrupted files but we
got them down now there you go I I got
to watch you with the fully loaded you
know it's 10,000 people or
whatever and this guy's doing I don't
want to give away but the raccoon bit
and it was just go AP it was great
that's F the fully load was C dude
remember the there was a guy that just
ODed or something in the middle
of my set oh yeah but enough about
[Laughter]
ber at the Gorge I forgot about
that that was a cool moment cuz it was
like you never you always are like how
are you going to react in weird
situations The Gorge is weird to begin
yes it's outdoors it's on a cliff
basically it looks gorgeous but it's
like you know and and there's how many
people like 15,000 it was crazy it was
insane he's selling so many
tickets it's like it's like it's insane
yeah but but it's like you know great
experience great Comics all that stuff
but it's not designed for comedy it's
hard to begin with and then in the
middle of my set a guy
passes out and then you have to kind of
do crowd work while a guy might be dying
I was I was just going to power through
that's how dumb my brain that's how I'm
used to just like clubs where I'm like
all right well this guy Show Must
Go On whereas like people were coming
out like stop right you can't you can't
be like asking a guy you know when the
last time he got his dick sucked while
somebody rest yeah but all the comics
you know it's me Santino and Bert like
how's he gonna pull this off he's
wearing a Valour tracksuit up
there and you we you had a great line
killed I think I was just like damn dude
that's embarrassing being such a
lightweight at the fully
L pass out we were just
on the guy for being like a
you were like he is gay you just
EMT zip a leather bag over his
head I know I was like I
was like all right if this guy dies it's
going to look bad but everything every
other scenario this is the line to go
with you got keep calculated risk
imagine that that's your last moment on
Earth yeah this
oh man I had a guy have a stroke
in my show it's it's standup Scottdale
years ago which was like he was on Bar
Rescue the guy how he was always the
nicest guy but like the next time I go
there it's not in the contract he's like
oh it's a new venue I'm in the back of a
Mexican restaurant I'm like oh guy in
the front has a has a stroke oh
my God and I'm just like oh call an
EMT like call something you know and
Howard gets on he calls an EMT then he
gets on stage and starts doing like
crowd work like geez I've had a stroke
before it's not fun right I'm like
you're doing stick ah there's no
Keith that's he was bombing as a
guy had it was brutal yeah the guy gave
a thumbs up and the way I'm like
hopefully all right yeah yeah yeah God
damn that's hilarious but Howard had a
stroke from like Red Bull and Coke it
wasn't like an honorable regular
stroke well salute to Keith I don't want
to give you know he has jokes about it
but it's like he got a dick pill stroke
that's is that right oh yeah yeah that's
one of the one of the big bits in the
special such a funny bit but I just
remember hear before it was a bit I
remember hearing that and just being
like that's a awesome guy yeah
one of the lines is like what what are
you willing to give up for sex that's
great that's great the stroke
salute are we doing because stavi does
advice we're doing stavi advice I'd love
that y yeah stav's world stav's world
hey Mark hey Sam my name is Malik
actually Sam I I met you virtually like
two years ago on like a
and the guest where the VIP guests could
like talk to you for a moment afterwards
and it made you laugh to be a cam girl
yeah times were tough during the
pandemic Sam showing boy
it's a lot of hair in that bush
stage sorry because I do stand up and
improv and I want to start wring sketch
start writing sketches and stuff like
that uh my previous goal was three times
a week and I pretty much beat that this
year so uh but something a problem I
have is I often do bits on people and
kind of on myself with myself socially
and they they uh socially often times
they go pretty well but sometimes they
bomb and then I'm like oh did I
make things weird uh how do you guys
what's the best way to get over social
bombing but still having fun like I
don't want to stop doing
it this is awesome this guy this guy
this guy is trying to like um patholog
this guy cares about standup comedy so
much that he has created a whole
terminology around being a bad
hang social bombing is not a thing buddy
you took a swing in a Miss it's just
like you're just people people just are
not liking your Vibe you got to stop
fing it's not the stage bro just
chill out have a good time don't
do too many bits nothing worse than the
guy who's always on constantly on you
know what I mean like especially when
you're starting standup right you don't
want to be that guy you have the forced
hangs right like open on the same lineup
right I remember there were some hilar
looking back at like the people you
shared a bill with oh my God mentally
deranged and I'm not saying you're that
guy but it's like but I do remember it's
here's the advice just keep it on stage
don't do bits you can call it
social bombing if you want what you mean
is being being annoying that's what
social bombing is if you want to bounce
a bit just say hey can I run a bit by
you or or like I just think it's a
different type of funny offstage and
than onstage yeah totally you're better
the compromise here would be hey if you
think of something funny and a in a
group hang and you say it and it kills
put it in your act but don't go the
other way don't go with your act in the
hang you know if you say something funny
maybe hold on to it and then put in your
act I can think is like sometimes
there's like stories that are maybe
different offstage to like you know like
they would work some of my best I mean
the threesome story in my act and then
the story that I tell in this speal in
the first special the threesome story
and in this special I tell like a a you
know a travel story that did start with
me calling my friends and being like
just telling them the story and believe
this and then doing a
version of that on stage and it growing
from
there but yeah stories I think are a
little different but I think our friend
here is talking
about not even running bits running bits
is fine you can always Comics he's
slipping them in he's like or even like
pretend like maybe even like pretending
something you know like I don't know
social bit has me a little worried about
what that means well it's
definitely not like pretending to
your pants or something yeah what soci
it's not fluid you can't be like hey I
uh I had a threesome on a GPS I had a
three ways guys guys what do you guys
want for dinner you know like just just
be dinner yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
that's my advice but on the bright side
like clearly you have a hunger for
comedy and and you're always on so like
use that for writing you know so that's
that's you know keep it on the stage for
sure keep that energy on the stage all
right next
one my New Year's resolution is the same
it's been for the past couple years uh I
want to do a pullup but um just one but
I'm I'm too fat I can't I can't you can
do it that was funny yeah I do pull-ups
every day just you know start start easy
you know like uh don't go all the way
down just do a halfed ones you could do
you can do I've seen people put like
there's machines at the gym where it's
like they help you where it's you up you
can do dead hangs I think that's good
though it's really good to have a
fitness goal that's just that simple cuz
then you could just be like all right I
can't do this now but can I are there
other exercises that will strengthen my
back they get there so it's like I think
you're fine now you might not hit it if
you stay fat you might not hit it this
year but you'll get closer it's just
having a North star and then you know
moving towards it I think that's a good
one agreed yeah Mark kind of inspired me
to do like I didn't do them back in the
day and I remember doing them once with
Mark on the street and and jerking my
neck out for a week and it was like I
was like this is motivation now I'm
doing them all the time because of
because the marks it's the best workout
oh yeah prism workout oh yeah that's all
you need yeah all right what do you got
here just going in the tub hey guys uh
New Year resolution work
less uh I have a good job and um I make
a lot of money and I'm going places in
my career but this Bond villain
seven days a week or sometimes 6 days a
week but then if I have a day off I just
sleep all day I would like to spend time
with my friends family like get like to
spend more time in the gym and uh have a
happy life but every day all day then
that's never going to happen so workless
newest resolution okay love you guys see
you it is hilarious to get a video from
a guy saying work less who's clearly
taking a bath yeah right right taking a
bath literally looking at himself the
entire time eye contact with the camera
you know what I mean just staring at
himself um yeah that's a great one I
think that's a beautiful you know you
both know I've harped on this I have
told both of you you need to work less
I'll be in Springfield Missouri uh
December 28th through
30th no but there's something to just I
get it too I mean I did the exact same
thing where it's like you everybody
sacrifice a little something different
to work this much CU I feel like it's
not going you know we're like ah this
might go away um exactly and it's you
know but I think I think I think our
friend over here has the right idea
where it's like yeah man you got to be
at a certain point it's like what are
you doing it for
continue to stack money and just
never have a good time and can't you
work he said he works six days a week
work four and just start there you know
maybe don't quit completely but a
regular week he said he makes
crazy money too so I don't I know yeah
so save that money what what's the
money for you know I know then
he sleeps all day so he's not even
spending it maybe on that Whirlpool he
had yeah yeah it looked like a shitty
bat it also looked like he just had like
a weird green Tupperware with all
shampoos inside yeah oh there it is yeah
what the is that that's where he
keeps the syringes and the uh who knows
what yeah that tile doesn't look
expensive do better buddy take better
baths get yourself a nice Whirlpool
there you go I'm trying to buy a sauna
that's how about a steam sauna over
steamer uh you could just get an
infrared sauna pretty easy that's what
I'm doing right into your house you're
doing that I'm doing it in the shower
it's the same thing just close the door
and let it steamy up yeah uh that's
cool that's dude the B you got
to come visit the Baltimore house I'm
trying to trick it out make it a little
Wellness
Center setting up a gym in the garage
I'm put sauna in there you know
damn dude yeah dude that's nice you got
your brother to work out brother's down
there and he's like he he's he you know
he runs his own business himself and he
was just like took he was just like I
should probably just hire employees
because I'm going crazy so before it was
like hard to work with him because it's
like he's just constantly running a
business by himself but he's hired
someone so yeah my brother's is going to
come through yeah we're I'm trying to
make it like a nice little nice little
Zone down great well what's that
neighborhood that Umar lives in it's
kind of that hipstery neighborhood hden
that's a great good neighborhood where
I'm more I'm on the I'm on the east side
close close to where I grew up I grew up
in southeast Baltimore and there's like
a there's like a park and then there's
like some water on the there's a
great walk you can do over there so I'm
kind of in between that zone I just
wanted to be around you know where
you go take a little stroll yeah that's
nice you know and near my family my best
friend moved back Baltimore she just had
a kid that little
my brother lives there my mom lives
there so it's kind of and then it's clo
my my other brother who's got the gym is
in the BBS um so it's like still a
pretty because umar's neighborhood is a
little it's a little of a pain in the
ass to get to from certain parts all the
parts that all my loved ones live in but
I love that neighborhood SP a lot of
time there stav is a major
celebrity in both of oh I can imagine we
we he'll I get phone calls sometimes on
his walks and literally 40% of the phone
call someone's like
stop stop I'm like all right let's
let this play out yeah yeah it is it is
crazy but yeah but it's nice I
still had to go right again who's next
that was straight up that was straight
up that was a neutral all right that was
Switzerland I am shocked that we have
cuz we were getting tagged by a lot of
women today for the Pod for that Spotify
wrap-up I'm shocked women listen to this
women like a good fart my wife farts
like a Clan member I mean it's
crazy I don't know the correlation but
you know I needed something saying slurs
while she's in black
face you guys see the Chiefs kid that
kid the Chiefs game oh my God a dead
spin right up that he he had like black
on one face and they only uh they only
showed one side only show that he had
they were like he's in black face and
then they turned his other side red he
was doing like the Chief there he is but
they got a major lawsuit now on their
hands oh the defamation look how cute he
is yeah I mean it's a we it still looks
weird I will say it's a crazy look no
it's racist against a different
group yeah it's like it's like hey let's
give him credit he's raced against two
both yeah exactly yeah the chief's
colors are not Black by the way like I
know again it isn't blackface but he
could have gone yellow white and red
yellow
Redway where where did he come up with
black is that the colors no yeah what is
weird that is interesting but yeah it's
funny how the black face took over the
headline but the the Indian thing is
worse to me it's way worse and I feel
like I see black people I don't really
see a ton of Native Americans the logo
though isn't it it's not the logo it's
just the name it's the all right yeah I
mean but it's yeah it's the Blackhawks I
think aha that looks more like the
Blackhawks there you go all right okay
well it looks like he's a n oh he is
he's part of a tribe too he's good I
mean that's the funny thing is they
would like say but he is like yeah he's
whatever that's funny though to only
show the black side yeah yeah they know
what they're doing yeah look at that
well de spin sucks dick now didn't it
get bought bought up by like the same
thing that happens to every
Media company is like a like some big
money will will buy it up and
fire every actual journalist and kind of
like only scabs will write for it or
like sports illustrator just got
using AI yeah and making fake pretending
it wasn't making fake journalists oh no
and they they're denying it but it it
clearly happened oh no so up it's
happening it's all happening right now I
saw I saw a boy Howard Beck post that
yeah shout out to Beck he got laid off
from Sports Illustrated and then they do
this there you go and Howard's a
great writer so great writer and that's
the thing it's like sports illustrat
used to actually they used to act I mean
it was it was journalism it's sad dude
yeah damn look that's the guy
clearly so fake whoa Drew
Ortiz could be lier named Ortiz right
blue eyes yeah they made him handsome
yeah yeah he is hot it is funny when you
see these headlines where you're like
see this woman with 11,000 followers
that a lot of people have jacked off to
she's
fake see a lot of those headlines now
and you're like I don't know how to feel
like yeah I'm okay I got
off anyway yeah it sucks dick but more
advice yeah sorry I shoehorn that kid in
there
totally I don't want to be all queefy
but of course I'm a huge fan of the
podcast I was just wondering if you have
any life advice for an 18-year-old who
doesn't know what he wants to do in the
future cheers oh wow oh that's a tough
one most open-ended thing this is very
about him well I would say go outside
for a minute I feel like a lot of these
18-year-old kidss they got the noise
cancelling headphones on they're staring
at a screen YouTube Reddit video games
all day get out there live a little
don't take on any debt school you know
what I mean even though he sounds he
sounds like he's from England so I don't
know how their Works true but don't
if you were in America I would say do
not go to college no Google scholarship
and then fck learn trade I would I would
go plumber dude well that's
going to be really necessary in the
future I would go construction
or Plumbing or yeah electrician you can
start electrician absolutely or Tech
those are your two things
don't go to liberal Art
School no no unless you get a
scholarship and even then I don't even
know it works so in England huh I don't
even know how it works in England I
don't either I don't know if it's free
they just they I don't know who gives a
it doesn't matter make some
friends grou follow more like yeah like
you know do stuff go out live life don't
have different experiences don't watch
porn all day yeah don't feel like you
have to immediately start your life you
really don't now is the time or like
know what you're doing it's kind of nice
to not know what the going on and
to just go just do travel see different
now's the time to open up your
horizons because you don't want to be
like well I had to go to school and I
had to go to grad school and
then you look up you're 32 you're in
debt you've had like two relationships
and you don't like either of them right
you're the guy in theb yeah you're the
guy in the tub
yeah exactly a little baby get out there
yeah you got you got to be back of story
right um yeah I can I can go to I can go
another 510 all right like do you want
to do one more or which
sure oh okay uh oh yeah
check hey Mark hey Sam my name's Charlie
I'm in my mid
20s I was in a band now that band
doesn't exist because my drummer just
moved away and
what uh uh ban drummer moved away hey
Mar what you guys would do if you were
in this situation or maybe some pointers
for being on stage in general also big
peeve I hate it when people try to
control the volume at which you speak at
and big rock Queens of the Stone AG the
bandj cat can't wait to see you guys
live and qu yeah didn't we get didn't we
get a didn't the guy from Queens of the
Stone AG want to come on here oh that's
right what's his name again Josh Josh
yeah he's supposed to be cool I like
that band yeah good band okay I got to
get into them dude something that breaks
my heart is that I had like an off for a
video they wanted me to play like a
Roman emperor in that like to be like a
guy eating you know
turkey leg and everything it was just
like I had a stretch last it was when we
were going to Seattle it was
like I I it was like right before my
special it was like Portland Seattle La
special the movie too right and then
right after the special movie and it was
like there was no I would have had to
like fly it was BR it was but it breaks
my heart cuz that's a sick band yeah and
I like their I think they're like
soder's favorite right sod loves them
exactly yeah uh also his peev is people
trying to control the volume that you
speak at that's weird again some of
these need context well I don't is that
like people being
like are you being a exactly
you're at a library screaming like take
it down man that's to tell someone I've
been on flights where people are so
loud I'm like do you mind just
keeping it and then they look at you
angry but you're just like I'm just I'm
asking politely yeah you're talking to
the guy next to you why are you
screaming I don't understand it yeah I'm
usually sitting next to Gary Veer and we
talk at a like a low respectable you
know nothing okay peeve this isn't even
like you know this is so so classic but
man when you just get caught in that
airplane convo you say you say one thing
against your better judgment
and you open the door a creek and this
sticks and then you're just like Yeah
well yeah it's like oh nice yeah
podcasting is good and how does he know
how have I told revealed so much about
myself like and the worst part is when
they just will not they won't stop stop
so it's like I have at least I at least
been like all right I have I have to
just I faking
that same you gotta fake but it's like
there should be like you should be able
to you need to have like a 90 second
timer there should be like three levels
of of airport conversation or Airline
conversations like just a nice back and
forth a nice let's give it two minutes
or under sure and then in two minutes
you need to both silently press X or
check mark two check marks all right
you're you're renewed for five minutes
yeah I like this like and then it's like
and then after that and then after that
it's basically like the whole flight
which is the only scenario I can think
of is it's a hot woman you're trying to
yeah yeah but other than that yeah
that's one that popped in big
cans we can old woman you got jacked off
bying Reno with big fake can I remember
the story of course I don't think I've
ever gotten off an airplane I got
a steward or a flight attendant's number
once and then uh it was fake yeah but
she was really
pretty that was a sad and I would not
stop I called it I tried every digit I
was like maybe it's a six maybe it's a
seven and I moved on in that's the the
second and last
number mathematically there's one
billion
possibilities tried them all tried them
all I was like a beautiful mind up there
with the chalk and the the
window oh yeah nothing I called United I
was like what was that lady's name with
the cleavage and the iPad yeah nothing
United gave you a fake number too yeah
uh yeah dude that's the airplane
is yeah I tried it once with a
stewardess and I got shut down to of
course it was an LA you know I'm sure
you get hit on all day long oh my God
yeah she's hot too hot so hot so hot ex
actress you could tell you know didn't
work out and if you caught her maybe in
a minor City maybe
maybe you know pipy or or something like
that LAX to pyy
direct I don't even know if they have an
airport pip no that's my go-to small
town it's a funny word absolutely the
thing I was doing canceled so I have a
couple more minutes actually not have to
be here all day but uh we don't have to
rush out either all right um but yeah
that's I mean that's a standard peeve
you know we could we could bounce bits
we could do a couple do a bit I'll do a
bit let me see what I got got too I got
a couple that are like
ideas I have one that I can't quite I
have a couple new ones that are actually
working BL but there's one that
uh um yeah actually there's a couple I
would like to well there's something
there's something horrible about like if
a girl rejects you outright M you can
always always be like if she had just
give me a chance it would you know I
would have Charmed her that
feels bad but I've discovered that what
feels way worse is a girl that you
exactly one time does not want to hang
out it's like man I really up you
know what it's like I had the chance
it's like when you bomb a job interview
don't get the job versus getting the job
and then getting fired after the first
day you know
funny yeah like he's like no no we knew
you yeah yeah yeah we gave you a shot we
knew exactly who you like yeah in the
other scenario you didn't get the chance
to know me right right right right you
didn't get the chance to know me I
didn't get you didn't get we hung out
and then kind of going along with it is
that like um it cuz I also cuz then you
think like how did that happen whatever
and it's like it sucks when you think
you had a really special like
fun magical like night or two with a
woman and you realize oh she was in the
spiraling and that was her Rock Bottom
it's like what you thought was like we
were out all night drinking and you know
we were making out and she was like we I
got to see you tomorrow and we're
getting up and then we you know
we it you know my weird Airbnb and
whatever and it's like and then you like
see her again and she's like
yeah yeah we called off the engagement
I'm getting
sober try and kiss her and she's
like no of course not you know what I
mean where it's like where it's like you
know you just you think it's like wow
this is crazy and it's like no this is
what you thought was the best one of the
best moments of your life was her
spiral God that's that's a fun that's
there's something to that where it's
like and then you're like she starts
tell she starts opening up about it and
you're like oh my God she's like she
tells you a story like oh yeah I just
the the guy I met at 7-Eleven and
you're like we hung out twice before you
let me you some other guy from
kitos you
know so I don't know there's something I
think if I could kind of just Mash both
of those in there together I like the I
like the job interview I like that it's
like getting to know you is good too it
sucks yeah it sucks when you put in work
yes and then fail or and also it sucks
me you get a really thoughtful rejection
oh you know what I mean it's like they
pre-wrote it where they're just like
they really really don't want to
they really thought it through you can't
even this can't even be uh an accounting
error on her part like this is
wrong it's like no no no she crossed her
eyes she crossed her tee noted her eyes
this is not coming out in your favor and
then you're like and then you're like
could I better and it's not like
I good the one time you know what
I mean you're thinking all right I'll
get another shot at this you know it
never comes I like the idea of the big
drawn out rejection thoughtful like
she's got a PowerPoint she's got a a
spreadsheet you took time yeah into
thinking about why you didn't want to be
with me yes yes already me once
once is so tough give me two you should
you give me two give me two that
happened to me with a roommate actually
once I kind a crush in her and we
once and then and she was like we can't
ever do that again I was like all right
see you tomorrow yeah yeah a bummer I'll
bring the electricity bill tomorrow
yeah wow did you give her good
though we were both pretty up I
mean it was probably fine it was
probably like not terrible yeah mine was
brutally bad really I was also on a
bender don't get me wrong what did I
have that day Peruvian chick well I was
just I was in the middle of like getting
really up and it was like it was
the first it was literally the first
time like kind of started trickling
like we it was the first like month
after posting and everything was going
like it's like the push it to the Limit
Montage it's like what the every clip is
going viral I'm gaining 10,000 YouTube
followers a day I'm selling out and I'm
just like getting up I'm like you
know I'm I'm a bunch of girl and
then she was like she was so hot too she
was like exact just you know huge
titties tatted up the whole thing love
the and uh and it was just like you know
I was I was just getting up
eating like I was on I had just
rented a sick like Airbnb I had like a
week off you know in a cool City it was
just like I was going all out so I think
I was just whatever you know T you know
tacos what I was on the W Coast okay
getting drunk I was and I'm not a big
drinker I was getting up I was
drinking I was smoking weed I was doing
mushrooms I mean I was it was a nice
time I you know what it was it was like
right after I had lost all the weight so
it was like nothing cuz I lost a bunch
of weight in the pandemic and I was just
like just the beginning of the
decline I've said this many times
nothing better than the first couple
months of a relapse before while you
still have all the good your body still
has all the positive you're Health hit
you yet and you're like I'm
Invincible I'm not going to gain
weight you know what I mean it's like
your life is in slow motion to like
cool music dude literally the
day I it was when the when when
the like when everything started hit
when it was like all the consequences
started hitting I was like I feel kind
of weird you know what I mean it was
like right after my birthday I was got I
was real hung over you know just a whole
whole thing but anyway damn so there's
that
one that bit I think there's definitely
a lot there and it's very relatable yeah
I got to get something there there's a
lot there yeah you're her I don't want
to say you're her rock bottom but see
that's the thing I feel like I've heard
that exactly exactly same and it's not
that it was I don't think I was her Rock
Bottom I which is maybe even more
embarrassing I'm not even memorable I'm
just on the way down right F I'm one of
many I don't get my own if it's a movie
I'm in a montage I don't get a scene
yeah right it's a split second shot of
me just like mashing my soft dick in you
know I mean and like a whole thing of
you know 7-Eleven is the scene I'm just
on the way down you know she'll remember
the Rock Bottom it's funny yeah yeah
over time she'll forget me yes yes
exactly oh that's pretty good that's
pretty good all right you're the rock
middle the rock middle all right what do
you got I got to look at my notes Here I
didn't look I got I got some ideas I got
a bunch if you guys want me to go I mean
go ahead man we I'm trying to think
what else they have here this is a less
relatable one but it's about uh
Like a Porn girl who's done porn where
you're like um or like a professional
you know like a escort off the clock or
even on the clock whatever I'm sex
positive whatever but it's like whenever
you a girl who's professionally
good at sex it's just like you're just
like you know well first I have this
thing that's that might be a little hack
I said it once or twice where it's like
don't Google before don't watch the
videos before actually I think the
premise is good but um where it's like
if you're going to girl does porn
don't Google her before oh yeah because
it's just like you don't want to you
don't want to know what's happened
before you know what I mean you don't
know what you're up you don't want to
see her two hands with plenty
of like might I oh that's great that's
great it's almost like you Yelp the
restaurant before you went or something
yeah yeah yeah but that's that's helpful
that's yeah yeah that's helpful that's
no good yeah it's not even like the
restaurant got bad reviews cuz she's
doing a great job doing a great job it's
just with hotter guys or bigger dongs
yeah yeah it's like Mark right though
it's like an analogy thing where it's
like I was thinking like basketball at
first where it was like but like that
wouldn't be oh maybe it's like uh you're
on like a high school football team and
you're like we should watch the game
film of the other team and they're just
like giant destroying everybody and
you're like even then you should watch
the that's true that's true look for an
edge yeah good point edge here but maybe
you have an edge maybe you're like oh I
can eat better than this guy or
something maybe that's your Edge but
it's really just that you know it's just
really that the dick is so big and she's
hammered you know you're not capable of
yeah sucks to follow that yeah and also
you're like wait why do you want to
follow that but it doesn't but here's
the thing if you didn't watch it it
doesn't it turned out great it's that
it's never been a thing where This
Woman's like geez I wish your dick was
13 Ines yeah it's always been a good
time and that's what the second part
that I'm that I like better I just think
there's something funny to the premise
of don't Google I think so too it's also
funny you could say like you know LeBron
plays against Kevin Durant and he has
and he has fun but he also shoots around
with a make a wish K sometimes that's
that's actually that was that's the
second part where I'm like where I'm
like but it's not but it's all it ends
up being fine because what I've been
saying is it I have used LeBron before
but the one I'm doing now is like you
know Lance Armstrong doesn't want to do
the tour to France every time sometimes
he wants a leisurely bike ride he wants
to put a little baguette in the
front of the basket stop and have a
picnic halfway through you know what I
mean you should pause go it's a very
little baguette it's
a it's not a great it's more of a roll
right
so I don't know it's it's
working yeah it's working but it's like
I need a little you know when something
you're like you like this premise but it
just doesn't yes totally smash I
got a couple of those following yeah
following something funny about
following a porn star too though it's
just like that's their job it's like it
might be a comp to you the way you do
comedy like like look on stage I I Crush
but you know offstage like if someone
laughs at every like I want to be a
person right might be some comp I'm
trying to think well maybe like you ever
go out with a girl and she's like you're
a comedian this date you haven't said
anything funny you know and you're like
well I do it there you know it's the
same with Lance Armstrong like I do the
two of friends but now I'm just riding
on the pier you know following yeah
following a guy
who's it's just and it's also something
just about your confidence yes where
it's like it just wrecks your conf it's
just like it's information you don't
need and ultimately it doesn't yeah
maybe there's something to it's
ultimately not um it's not even
necessary or helpful yeah you know what
I mean it's like it's information
overload it's like right right like
looking up a cooking recipe is helpful
now I know how to make it this is just
going to give you insecurity I want to
see pictures of the ve being
slaughtered that's not bad that's not
bad that's a good line yeah you don't
need to see the K the chicken in the
little cages you
know just enjoy the chicken just enjoy
the chicken that's pretty good there's
something there I like that or you could
make it about the farm animal getting
you know I need to see the guy
the cow just want some
ribs but yeah there's that's good that's
funny that that's not bad the the animal
thing yes yes okay we got we got to be
somewhere 2:30 just so you know oh we do
but let me could probably do one
let me do a if I have anything
is this is this stupid I'll be quick um
my buddy we were going out to eat for
like a couple nights in a row we were on
the road and I go oh you want to get
pizza and he goes ah pizza again we had
pizza last night and I was like well
don't ever get married because it's the
same every night you know like
it's weird how with food we're like oh I
want all this variety but like you know
when you're married you're like this is
it this is the the vagina yeah you know
I can't be like I uh I had Cheryl last
night you know yeah yeah I don't know it
might be a quickie a quick joke but I
don't know is it is I don't know if
there's anything there um yeah something
like there could be something there
about maybe variety in food is is like
how we overcompensate with the same
woman yeah I mean it's just it's it's
that it's like not a one for one
necessary analogy of right like you know
what I mean that's the problem is that
like it does make sense and it is funny
but there's not depth to it where it's
like CU if you if you go one layer down
it's like well you don't love the pizza
exactly exactly and you eat three meals
a day if the pizza if the pizza like you
know was there for you
when your father died in a car accident
maybe you would have it every day you
know I mean like you know something like
that yeah that's true there could be
something to flip it on the other side
yeah or maybe like how with with your
wife unlike P Pizza you eat the same way
every day but with your wife you try to
mix it up so no one's ever been like I'm
gonna eat pizza backwards today I'm
going to put the pizza up my
ass yeah I like that better actually
like from that angle of like cuz it
isn't a Perfect Analogy of that's good
that might be the way to flip it of you
because it's like it is kind of on its
head simplistic it's not an A to B yeah
but it's better that way to show that
it's not an A to B I think I'll try that
way yeah all right whose titties are
these they were given to us for from the
South Park guy's wife oh nice yeah we
got I had one something maybe here about
how social media depresses you but it
depress it's like the people doing well
who depress you it's like it's like a
guy who's like just got a job promotion
I got the best wife in the world I love
my little girl and you're like this
you know but then like if
someone posts like hanging on by a
thread uh life is not worth living I'm
like I like this guy you know and you're
like in your head you're like don't
kill yourself cuz I'm not going
to have a a daily pickme up you know
like who am I GNA who am I GNA you need
like but I I don't know where to go with
it because it's like that part hits but
I need like I think the point is like
people say social media feel makes you
feel bad but it's like people people
thriving people who are not sad make you
feel change the algorithm the problem is
we see too many successful people right
let's get a couple train wrecks
here like the algorithm supports like
handsome hot people talking about
success I want pushed to me where
it's like you know I've lost it all a
guy's got a noose around his neck it's
like a boomerang he's like you know I
want to live watch a guy miss the last
leg of a 10 leg parlay that would have
saved his life but now
now you know what I mean now he's out
100 Grand I want to watch that I don't
want to watch a guy get I don't want
wedding pictures well there is a giant
genre on the internet called fails oh
really oh yeah just guys like falling
over more America's funny that's true
that's true I think we're talking about
like you know more of like emotion F you
know right right a guy at a roulette
table caption just lost my daughter's
college fund I want I want more of that
there should be a sad algo yeah that
should be like an app I get too much of
like chicks with great asses just being
like I work pretty hard for this like
all right well that that makes you happy
that doesn't bum you out no it does it
it it bums you out oh that's true that's
true that's true problem maybe it's
something about how like people work in
rehab clinics must be the happiest
people ever like man I'm doing great
everybody's coming in here with
pill addictions and they about to kill
themselves and I'm awesome yeah that's
good I also I also a quick thing about
like I don't know where to go with this
one about uh seeing a girl she travels a
lot for work I travel a lot for work I
got I it's weird I'm a comedian because
I can't tell when people are joking like
I I was uh I was like man it's so hard
uh so hard just not seeing you ever and
she's like well you should you should
you know a prostitute and I was
like
yeah and she was like are you
kidding me and I was like oh I didn't
like I didn't can't throw that out there
I know that was like a mean
dangle but it's also not great that I
bit that hard
right you know what you should do is get
down on one knee and she's like really
you're like no what are you kid
me that's good flip it on I like that
turn all right that's a good
turn cuz that's the girl's prostitute
you know that's a female prostitute is
that yeah you can't dangle that no
that's crazy no that's insane I like
that but you know I don't know that the
premise is even the comedian thing it's
like there is something about that
that's so much more relatable than that
where it's I mean the comedian thing is
a good way to get into it but there's
something more to it about why you bit
so hard you yeah you really show who you
are in those moments absolutely
absolutely absolutely cuz there's so
yeah because it's it's not it just shows
what you really want or you know what I
mean where it's like prostitute is just
such a good one though I know I know
better than that one well yeah I mean it
is cuz it's like you could I could see
the dirt bag logic of like yeah I mean
it's like it would mean nothing I'm just
coming I mean I can't what I can't jerk
off right I'm up in the economy these
are single mothers probably you know
what I mean sex work is real work
absolutely it's work it's harder
hard it's one of the it's harder than
almost every type of work definitely can
you imagine oh yeah yeah I mean you know
like we you entertain you know it's like
starting standup where it's just like
you entertain people you hate it's like
imagine you also have to suck those guys
there no way they like half most
of the people they have to your
brain is like well I'm one of the good
guys I'm good there you go I'm a nice
change of pace for her yes and you're
but you've just been saying all this
your girlfriend has left you you know
what I me just she's packing her stuff
power you have like eight bullet points
ready to go she's been packing the whole
time I like that though there's
something there all right well stop
where you going to be uh Mo the most
important thing is watch the special fat
Rascal fat Rascal I I'm going to take a
lot of time off but the last I I got Co
hilar embarrassing to get Co now yeah
what a nerd I get it I did get it and it
me up so I had I'm doing a couple
makeup shows uh Dallas is actually from
the taping of the special I had to make
those up because great venue really I
can't wait I'm sorry sorry for missing
it Dallas uh but Dallas Detroit Grand
Rapids I'm making up all the those were
left over from the fat Rascal tour I'm
not adding any I will announce a tour
for later next year but for the time
being I'm taking some time off H yeah
but so these are the last chance to see
me and uh yeah you might there might be
some stuff off the special what the
do you want from me I play this really
nice where the tour ended and I was I
had no dates I got sick and it's like
well there's going to be third 20
there's going to be 20 good minutes you
haven't seen there's going to be 10 bad
ones yeah there's going to be 10 minutes
of crowd work 15 well maybe 20 and then
there's going to be 15 minutes of stuff
from the hour that's probably
how it's gonna break out that's
realistic not so bad folks not bad yeah
maybe JP will do maybe I'll bring more
people like three openers you pull up a
Cris
Katan yeah eldis is gonna try stand up
for the first
time you just throw your friend out the
bus like man that guy sucked right
looking at your watch yeah I make him
wear the worst
outfit out for 10 minutes yeah there you
go I write the jokes for him so I have
that's not a bad
idea you're pro pro Putin I heard your
act
all right I'm going to be at Deja Vu no
um Kansas City norfol Baltimore with
Umar Burmingham sheveport Tampa Tampa
Jacksonville Columbus Ohio Indianapolis
New York at the Beacon Lexington
Charlotte San Antonio Houston we got a
markn Norman comedy.com and we're
grinding baby we're doing it got to
build some new
hour I am I've heard it's a beauty Inc
sick nice back in clubs for a short
minute before the special in March and
Boston I think Boston's already sold out
baby but we got Buffalo Springfield
Madison Philly Stamford daa Beach Omaha
Dallas OKC Irvine Salt Lake City uh The
Wilbur for the taping baby let's
rock hell yeah hell yeah all right thank
you gang sam.com get some Bodega cat get
Bodega cat whiskey bodat whiskey.com
stavi baby is Netflix Special stav's
World produced by eldest we love you
Matt Peters
you guys look like a before and after a
glow
up sorry no one will get that joke at
home but thank you thank you guys thank
you hey good app what an
[Music]
app
and
the on the roof like a cop's coming and
naked Samuel is feeling
dangerous I'm out to lunch here in New
Orleans this woman doesn't look like I
remember and I get down in the same
way we
might
be
true